and we are live ready for the junior
speed chess champion final i am grand
master robert hess and of course
alongside me today
as usual is grand master daniel diskey
donya we have a
thriller in the making between mihal
sarin and alexis serrano
what are you expecting from today's
final match
robert a pleasure to be doing this again
uh for the last time
the stage is set for an incredible
showdown both of these players are
amazing in and of themselves
they have also survived trial after
trial challenge after challenge
and they have made it to the finals
against each other alexis arana
and nihal saren i am expecting
the most thrilling match yet robert and
that is saying a lot
because we have seen some pretty darn
thrilling matches already
we certainly have and if we you know
bring up the smarter chess predictions
brought to us by chess goals
in this final between nihal sereno
alexis saranac
it's going to be a pretty you know
balanced matchup but you see the final
prediction down there
14 to 12 in nielsen's favor 63
win probability and interestingly enough
sarnath has the
edge i would say in the longer time
controls and he showed that he evidenced
that against jeffrey chong
in the semi-final right he just was
dominant in the earlier stages despite
having some shaky positions
he did uh and he showed some superb
opening preparation and he showed uh
incredible
ability to adjust to different time
controls but
uh nihal is nihal we all know of his
prowess in all time controls
his ratings reflect that and he has
played incredibly in all matches so far
uh he's just a force to be reckoned with
but this is i don't even know what to
say these are both
such beasts for sure let's uh remind
everybody of the overall bracket to see
how they got there
nihal knocked up andrew tang who
qualified his way in then beat anton
smirnoff and it was a pretty close
matchup
and then looked dominant against hike
marching rose and that was
probably the most surprising result in
the entire bracket
and on the other side of things alexis
saranac he beats his compatriot
andre issapenko then takes down the
americans sevien and zhang
and now he's facing off against nihal
sarin so i mean
anything surprising there i feel like we
just come to express
expect excuse me it's a success
we have but if if you remember it's
crazy
panko is already a monster and to beat
him in the first rounds not to mention
you know the other two matchups
and the same of course goes for nihal i
mean these players faced
uh incredible opposition in the very
first matchup not to mention
uh the next stages so uh to be able to
win time and time again dominant
performances against zhang against
marturosian
are are incredible i mean dominant
performances of any kind against
the best of the best here in the jscc
are always so impressive
certainly the case and you know for
sarina in particular
he beat higher rated feta classical
opposition i mean yes
panko is like 26 80 70 somewhere around
26.70
jefferson over 2700 so did he beat
anyone good
you know just some slackers here and
there and we do have liftoff d4 played
by
nihal and one thing i'm going to be
keeping my eye on
is the speed because neil has a tendency
to spend a bit too much time
in the early stages of the game whereas
whereas sarana was just
a speedster against jeffrey john he was
always up on time
and opening preparation is going to be
extremely important in
this match because that is what saranac
is known for
and nihal is going to have to show
but obviously not that nihal is not
known for that
so play very quickly in the opening yeah
what is this line here
wow take that e4 and then the bishop was
hanging
on a6 yeah i've seen this somewhere
i don't know these lines i can
understand what they're doing but if we
just back up
a second here the point was that after
knight takes g5
if then i want to capture queen takes g7
can happen hitting the knight
hitting the rook and the king is going
to be caught in the center probably to a
deadly attack so that's why black didn't
go scoop off this bishop over here
instead we saw a castle and after queen
takes were a6 if that knight moves out
the way down goes the bishop one g5
and then that's why white castles and
goes for an attack on the
king's side so dania black is up a pawn
for the time being that b5 is quite weak
as is c3
and is that still must be some kind of
theory because nihal is moving instantly
yeah probably some like bashiela grab
you know aronian game from 2017
uh you think you know wow this is a
crazy line and then you see like 18
super level games from you know norway
chess or i don't know why i'm out of
nowhere chess
but you know one of those tournaments uh
where you know pretty decent players
are playing normally like magnus uh man
can we compensate some actual players
robert but in any case
yeah so i used to actually play the
vienna for black which is what this is
called
i mean i don't know the ins and outs of
it i don't remember anything what i do
know is that white has now restored
material equality
but black has restored proper
development for his pieces i think
white's got the edge though if you look
at that e5 pawn
it's under some pressure you don't want
to take on c6 prematurely but you can
play rook fp1
and i think white is the one pressing on
the gas pedal here for the time being
yeah i'm with you there an action an
interesting move that i was thinking
about said f3 was bishop to f4
because i'm trying to take on c6 and you
can't move the pawn but i understand
that
it's a little bit too much uh you can't
just go and get away with things like
this often
i can protect the bishop like rook f6
and that way i can take your bishop when
you take my knight so
getting fancy could backfire it could
also work out sometimes but uh
he went and said f3 and rook a to d1 so
a little bit of a tamer approach
right and bishop b3 now the rook shifts
over to e1 having misplaced the bishop
king to h8
uh getting the king out of the potential
danger zone and i think
king h1 getting the king out of the
potential danger zone
and i did do you see that twice in a row
i'm just making sure that i heard that i
did
say that i did say that twice in a row
but now i think that
um nihal can try to well the battle
revolves around the e5 pawn
[Laughter]
and whether or not nihal will be able to
put sufficient pressure on it
the game could also fizzle out in some
kind of a draw
yeah it's interesting that in this
position black has the better center
white has the bishop pair and this
bishop on b3 you have to
be a bit careful not to leave it there
too long because if c4 happens
and i can follow up with an attack on
that bishop it could get trapped over
there however
c4 does free up the d4 square for this
black knight
and that's why that pawn is going to
remain on c3 for the time being
and dino rook came to d6 yeah i have
this
feeling that you know nihal will try his
best
to apply more pressure in the center but
i could see this game
turning from what i consider white's
favor into black's favor
if that center can expand eventually an
e4 type of move at the right moment that
can open up the position
and i feel like you have to be ready for
it all times yeah queen f2 comes to mind
here's something to that effect
preparing yourself against
e4 which does open up the f file i mean
of course you didn't necessarily mean
immediately i i agree i mean there's
a lot of things that white has to watch
out for in particular that center
um and and white has has to decide how
he's going to arrange his thesis is he
going to go for c4
or is he going to go let's say queen f2
queen c5 is that proposed
or is he going to go i don't know bishop
c1 bishop i mean there's a lot of these
maneuvers
that exist and are out there in the
ether but you have to
kind of pick one and stick with it and
that can be difficult
for sure another one i'll throw out is
bishop h4 bishop g3 is sort of
standard rerouting of the bishop you can
start with bishop f4 to go to g3 just
because this pawn e5
is pinned for the time being to the rook
on e8
so white has many different options and
nihal now is
a little bit behind on the clock because
he's spending his time here i personally
i would be in the same boat i would be
thinking which of these
options will work out best for me and i
i don't know bishop h4
h4 has that ring to it because it
attacks the e5
yeah so i i think putting the bishop on
g3 makes just a lot of sense here
right and um this is a critical moment i
think
it's understandable why nihal is taking
his time here
uh this you know it always seems weird
to say that this moment could decide the
game
but again i i think when you're
analyzing a game
you come back always to these types of
critical moments and either you
celebrate the decision making are you
saying man
you know i rushed or i didn't pay
attention to the right things
and here i think neal's just spending
too much time because he's what a minute
and a half or so
here i can see it now he just made the
movie h3 two minutes he spent
two minutes on the move h3 and even
though that's a perfectly fine move
he just now is in a hole in the clock
he's down a full minute
and we've seen sarnath match after match
give him a lead on the clock he
continues to put pressure on his
opponent
then when there is a time scramble he
often is the one who comes
out on top however we of course have to
acknowledge nihal is
an absolute machine in bullet chest if
anyone can get out of
a position with mere seconds on this
clock it is him yeah i'm still
thinking about his uh display uh i mean
several bullet displays
uh which have been just absolutely
marvelous i mean the speed the the
accuracy the intuition
uh but yeah we've seen serrano
particularly in the last match as you
said put pressure on the opponent
uh when when he's got 50 40 seconds on
the clock and here's all
dipping into his clock again queen to a5
attacking c3
another decision to be made for white
this is what sarah and i is really good
at
making forcing his opponent uh to make
decisions i would say queen e3 comes to
mind queen e3 queen c5
another idea um perhaps nihal is
considering bishop g3
and after queen takes it while he plays
it after queen takes e3 bishop c6
maybe restore material balance i'm not
sure about this something about this
seems a little bit off-road
yeah because the rook on e8 and there's
a queen on e2 and the rook typically
wins the battle but he says wait a sec
let me just steal your a4 i wasn't even
looking at the a4
that was kind of obvious in retrospect
yeah i know who was uh
lexi was and but done it's kind of
obvious in retrospect
that pawn is hanging now that he took it
but it's like wait isn't
you take on c6 with your bishop and
after bishop takes e5 you can put your
rook
on e6 and that will force white to move
the pawn to f4 that's a really big deal
because just to show something like this
is if you have to play f4 c3 there's a
problem down on g2 it's for this rook to
come to g6 in the future
and just like the bishop one e5 looks
very good uh the
bishop one c6 as a quincy there's a very
nice move that you spotted because the
queen
is not defended on e2 enough times yeah
the queen takes h3 as a threat there
geez so rookie six played f4 and then i
yeah i'll take on c3 here
you know just one nice tactical sequence
that works out in sarno's favor
and he doesn't have to i mean he's got
pressure on g2 that he could mount but
uh you know the opportunity train
doesn't come along twice in terms of
such a pawn
uh or as as grandmaster alexander o'neil
once told me
you know free puns don't just lie on the
side of the road
and he said that as a metaphor because i
was refuting
refusing the oars or dovers at the
opening ceremony of the us championship
and you know there were just sandwiches
lying there and he said
three pawns don't fly on the side of the
road and i immediately picked up a
sandwich and started
you took that wise you know the why
saying they're of a wonderful
grandmaster and i was in honor
hey donna you you know you saw queen c3
sarna follows your lead here
and king issue what do you make of that
decision to get
the queens on the board you know trading
off i think would have been bad because
the rook lends an e2 which is too much
activity for
black but if we think bigger picture if
you could just take the queens off the
board
as they are right now does that help
white or black black because of partly
because of the time situation because he
gets a blank check when it comes to just
making attempts and that g2 pawn is if
the rook lands on e2
white's rook is going to be saddled to
g1 i mean we've talked about this before
opposite colored bishops yes but the
rooks on the board lend the game a
far more combative character than if
they had been alone what i also liked
about nihal's decision
starting out is a minute and you know
you mentioned that you could see the
game turning in black's favor earlier
and it did
i can see the game strangely as the
sounds turning into
turning to white's favor potentially
because of that g7 pawn
particularly if white lifts his rook
from e3 to g3
yeah that looks like a very easy plan to
execute for
me neoliberal black is up at pawn but
it's irrelevant for the time being that
b-pawn is not pushing with so much
material on the board
so i think that sargon has to figure out
a way to save his king the f5 pawn is
under attack so maybe queen f8
king h7 g6 but it does feel risky to
push this g pawn
because then your dark squares are
permanently open does it
yeah this is i i feel like there it goes
king h7 that's exactly what he does and
here comes g6
yeah i mean he doesn't well he could
play rookie 7 but yeah that g6 now the
queen
drops to d1 and as you said robert the
diagonal
has opened up i don't know who's i mean
practically speaking i don't know who's
better now
sarnath has dipped on the clock yeah
saran
time trouble himself in fact nihal is
ahead and that i think bodes well for
white's chances you made the point that
you could see this turning around
it just feels like a position where
black's king is in worse shape than
whites because the pawn g2 is defended
while this rook on g3 is attacking
g6 you know it's protecting g2 but how
to make progress from here that's a
totally different question because you
can't play h4h5 the h4 square is covered
by
uh black's queen and he plays king to h1
that's an odd yeah it steps back into
the pin i mean you could play king h2
i don't think that well okay rookie what
he's really sort of
you know crouching and digging himself
this is a little bit odd from from neil
now h5 star not bouncing
rook to d3 trying to trade rooks okay i
think that's a bit of an
odd sequence yeah i think you just want
to trade a pair of rooks that's what
nihal was focused on
with the queen trade being offered oh it
could have traded queens i thought that
in
ending without the queens would have
been pretty easy to hold but he says
your king on h7 is still very weak here
he might be playing for a win
yeah that's brave that's definitely it
is
but if he plants the queen on g5 okay
he's coming okay b5 softens up the
bishop
sir arnold doesn't want to do that
that's a big concession and queen d8 is
nice to also stop something kind of
queen g5 right okay
okay that may be rook cafe now that is
another committal move
okay daniel i see there's a tactical
sequence there that i'll show after the
game you know in that rook 8 but i
just whoa g3 check watch out for a back
rank check maybe
but black's also got to watch both kings
of five seconds for both of them here we
go
we need six to go to h3 oh you oh
no okay trick quincy two queens you do
immediately
oh what a turnaround and nihal gets it
oh my wow goodness oh
we have to look at that that is crazy
and i want to see your sequence as well
all right let's go back to the analysis
board to bring up the
game that just finished uh so that's it
oops sorry bring up this yeah the one
sequencing you know you're
talking about this rook a8 move and
right here if rook a8
rook f8 i thought there was some kind of
queen g5 but there's not like queens
trying to like take on f8 and meet you
back here but unfortunately
after queen g5 queen takes the g2 pawn
is hanging with mate first my whole idea
was distract your queen
and take your rook and say hey your
queen's under attack and i'm meeting you
but of course g2
that would have worked actually had the
pawn been on g3 for example
yes if the palmer up one square that
would have worked but sadly it doesn't
with the
pawn g2 and towards the end of this game
danya it looked like
black was the one trying to play for a
win but rook d8 came
and he just was winning for black it was
winning
oh my gosh queen takes e5
365 is winning back
and it comes all of us i mean because
sarah and i was paying attention to that
h3 square
uh as as were we but uh wow
what incredible incredible stuff and it
said you found the checkmate the king
was ensnared by white's pieces and that
was that let's go to the second game
because that one is in full swing and
there's a pawn on g4 so i i look like a
normal position somehow the queen on d5
but then i saw white's pawn is on g4 so
the knight cannot capture the queen
it is pinned but you can either capture
the queen directly or capture this
bishop
so you can capture the queen next move
it's a very common type of idea but i
think the intermental queen takes
before there is no queen f3 because
queen takes f8 so what do you think
about this
queen takes bishop move down there um
it's i mean i like the two bishops
personally i think that
it can be easier to play with the two
bishops but there are certain squares
that the knights can jump to and he goes
bishop d2 now
decision for black does he take the
queen and go let's say knight a5
and go after that pawn again i'm sure
that this is still theory or queen a5
is the other i think option in my eyes
uh knight takes d4
doesn't work because of queen takes
queen actually that would have been
uh somewhat that would have led to some
wild complications but but that doesn't
work for black
so i think the real decision is between
queen a5 and queen takes c3 we take b3
yeah i just want to point out that
you were looking at this d4 square so
many tactics flying
in this position yes the black queen is
under attack but you're putting an
attacker on the
queen on b3 but instead he takes and was
rooked to d8
and if you try to analyze this position
you know full picture if we just started
trying to talk about descriptively
black's pawn structure is definitely
better
but white's bishop on f1 in particular
has the option
to take over the board compared to this
bishop on
c8 so has bishop d7 bishop c6 a
potential idea
maybe i don't maybe okay c5
but does that really fully let black
escape from some of the
potential problems because it's kind of
like a catalan type of position
right there's always going to be
pressure on the queen side that's right
on the money that catalan reference
because
sometimes you play c5 you take a deep
breath i finally liberated myself from
the troubles but
that bishop on g2 in combination with
some of the other squares on the queen
side he goes c6 so he takes a more
sort of uh passive bunker style approach
which is interesting because the bishop
on g2 is is now
blunted by the pawn sarina has more
active pieces but
i think nihal is going to be asking him
well how exactly do you make progress
i'm going to put my knight on d5
potentially put my pawn on a6
what is white going to do uh in order to
progress here yeah you if you play e4
you have to be very careful
because that loosens up your defense of
the d4 pawn i think you can
probably get away with it right now but
just as a sample line e4 knight c7 the
d4 pawn is already under attack and a
bishop e3 there's knight to b5
hitting your pin knight and hitting your
palm in the center so you have to be
really careful before you push
this e pawn because it does make this
deep on
like an immediate target right
and uh that can be a useful
tool in a blitz game rubber by the way
this idea
there's a move that you can play on any
move and on every move you have to
consider playing it but you never know
when to play
uh so that takes away and that was a
very convoluted sentence but that takes
away a lot of time
and i like what tsarnaev is doing here
connecting his rooks
and uh there's a lot of improvements
that he can make without playing
right he could actually play f4 he can
play g5 if he wants to if for some
reason kicking this knight away
feels correct but he can just start
expanding and black is
really passive here yeah b6 your bishop
was going to b7
a5 bishop a6 though that is a much
better plan indeed because the king on
e2 is not exactly in the
safest of positions right now that's
taking advantage of your opponent's
decision to keep having having played
knee hall and blitz games he's
incredibly good at this kind of defense
uh and
and he generates chances but but it's
not just
cheap tricks it's actual annoying
defensive attempts
and that's exactly what you have to do
in a position like this you don't go for
the full nine yards immediately you go
for a little bit of activity
you breathe some nervousness in your
opponent and then you go from there
yeah for sure and i mean look at what
sauron just did he went
knight d3 a couple moves ago and then
brought his knight right back to e5 and
it feels like he's wavering a bit trying
to figure out how to prevent black's a5
bishop of a6 you pointed out that idea
it's a very good one
and he takes on d5 so interesting
transition
dania where you take on d5 you have the
worst queenside pawn structures but your
rook on h1 is very quickly coming to c1
and your rook on a1 perfectly placed
hitting the a7 block
right and we indeed see this
transformation in the pawn structure
bishop d6 to cover that c7 square
and yes the position has transformed uh
i don't think this is an unwelcome
transformation for
for nihal especially if he can smoke
that knight out of e5
yeah i think the only way you can really
smoke it out is by capturing it because
this knight can go to c6 at some moment
just taking
advantage of the fact that there's a
vulnerable light square and it's a
fiance bishop but it's not a pawn
so in comes the knight b5 of course is
an idea
for sarah knott push that one forward to
cement control of that square
and you know anytime you take on e5
you're doubling white's pawns
but you're giving up more control the c
file in particular this
c7 square so dania i don't think you're
going to take on e5
yeah no something tells me it's a little
bit too too committal he goes a6
and he sets up a barricade stopping b4
b5
well you know what he walks into right
is knight c4 because your bishop on b7
is not defending
no you did bishop c7 knight
right because i'm attacking your bishop
and your pawn bishop c7 looks like it
defends both but knight a5 and
your bishop is under attack down in the
c5 both your sharp today he goes g5
instead that could be helping black
in the event of knight d7 right and
knight d7 that will protect the pawn on
b6 very importantly because this knight
c4 tactic
uh is a nuisance because precisely that
pawn is left undefended
and i think that this knight c4 idea you
should always be on the lookout when
bishops are staring each other down and
what happens if the piece in between
them
is removed and that's why knight c4 it's
a relatively common tactic
in certain variations uh so i was just
keeping an
eye on that but done it so now that he
has not played knight to c4
i guess he can play it if this knight
but the knight really is only two
squares
or unless you take an e5 first which
perhaps you can consider you can but i i
don't think so i i would not part ways
of that bishop which is holding together
the
c7 square i think he is deciding between
98 and 97 because 98 has also the
benefit and then you can play f6 he does
go 97
uh taking this thing out of knight c4
again he can go f6 here or he can delay
it
um you could go b5 conceivably but that
is a very
responsible move i don't like that
because that weakens the knight e3
that b5 move just is asking for it
giving connections right right
exactly and this is the good thing about
the double pawns is that b5 knight b6 is
always about pawn b2 to b3
taking away the very nice looking c4
square from your knight so
the knight gets into c5 yours does not
get into c4 so
b5 unfortunately possible f6 that's kind
of a tough move psychologically to play
because then you soften up the e6 square
and you like the look of this pawn chain
on the light squares
culminating in the d5 h4 and the bonsai
moves okay again f6 is is is the move
you're considering i would go king e7
first probably yep
but now you've allowed a knight which
would happen
but is he against training bishops he
might be um well i guess we'll find out
one other thing don is now white to play
f5 because d5 is no longer defended so
if white wants to start chiseling at the
structure
uh you can go directly for that yeah
and um okay we're okay seven so he's
trying to hold things together yeah i
agree with you f5
is an idea e4 there also was almost a
mating idea it sounds weird but
right like if the rook was on c1 yeah it
still exists
it can play rooks like one he could play
b5 and try to take this thing
wow it doesn't work anymore but it was
just keeping an eye out on this rook
take d6 sec it said nihal is ten seconds
look at the time yeah that's great that
is i mean and the position is
that rook takes b6 bishop c7 he wants to
play
okay that's the number three bishop e3
you hit you take back on b6 with a fork
yeah that might actually maybe you take
and go rook d7 how bad is that is the
question
i'm wondering the same exact thing he
does do it he hasn't oh
he is rupee five rookie five same idea
oh wow it's incredible and he'll find it
he's got time
the work on a7 is still hanging back
there so rook b5 is a move that saves
rookie please
66 no that's definitely a concession
okay and he goes b5 now he finally
exploits that rook he's still
dominating here i would say yeah you
played b4 oh but then a takes b5 so do
not play b4 that actually
hangs the pawn yep so what
oh a b right the rook is undefended yeah
and then thankfully
rook c1 maybe roof c1 looks really nice
just attacking this bishop
you don't want to trade too many pieces
for white because what you ideally want
to do is swing your rook to c8 and then
over to h8 like start winning some of
the
king side pawns keeping pressure on both
sides of the board but wait a speed five
he blundered it will nihal say it he
dies
that's a big time swing now rook a7
bishop d3
oh but that knight c6 and you can't even
take the pawn that was a big blunder
it really was a rook c8 rook h8 still a
possibility but that black mango d7 to
f8 to
not only protect h7 but shut your rook
off from getting back in the game
wow wow wow uh-oh this is incredible now
that you only think four seconds bishop
c6 would threaten checkmate bishop takes
before
it opens up the square for the king he's
got one second he's got to move he
barely got that off and bishop oh she
goes up six
oh
king e4 and mate next move with bishop
wow take on possum only
yeah bishop seven that was incredible
resistance but i mean too little time
yeah bishop g5 is it's unfortunately for
it nihal it's over
and honestly 1-1 feels about right thus
far both players coming up with really
good interesting ideas nihil
almost saved that game and and for
sarina
when he has more time he cannot miss
moves like a takes b5 he's
far too strong to like overlook that
right i completely agree and um he
we know that he apportions his time very
well uh but as you say he he's got to
use it properly in the critical moments
and
nihal was very sharp in time pressure
unfortunately
uh when you've got five seconds and
there's a lot of pieces on the board
your king is weak it's
it's humanly impossible to defend
against all of the threats at the same
time
and nihal sauron plays a different line
this time he put knight b5 in the first
game now he brings the bishop back to d2
and starting at castles i was drawing
arrows and knight takes e4 with
my queen g4 clearly there's some sort of
theoretical sequence that i
i can't pretend to know but nihal
playing very quickly with the white
pieces in both games this far
yeah um both of them seem relatively
comfortable
now a6 what's the make of this position
again two bishops for white
uh white has some pressure on the center
he can play off four
but obviously he's got that deficiency
in the queen side bond structure
black's got a nice queen on a5 he goes
f3 a more measured approach
reinforcing that pawn on e4 yeah f3 is
saying i
don't want my queen tied down there and
just in case you had b5 bishop b7 have
any ideas of that
not going to allow you to hurt my center
so the e4 pawn and the f3 pawns restrict
the knight and f6 you've talked many
times with the
superfluous knights knight on d7 knight
on f6 not quite the case here because
nightmare
probably does want to go to c5 or even
e5 into c4 so
black's knights are all right for now
but i prefer the potential of the
bishops
right i agree if you can stabilize the
situation bring the pieces in
another maneuver to keep in mind is the
queen from e2
can do a lot of different things it can
go from f2 to h4 potentially
and here we see niho allowing turnout to
take the bishop
uh but that correct white's pawn
structure i would still very seriously
consider it though
i think he won the five square this
weekend right i think he threw an e5
as a means of just gaining space and
opening this bishop one state he could
play bishop e6 as well so if
he'd prefer not to trade the knight for
the bishop but keep this knight on c5
it cannot be attacked by a pawn so it's
a pretty good square for it and
keeping the pawn structure ruined for
white then bishop e6 is an idea but then
c4
exactly we're about to say the same
thing he takes it oh
yeah i noticed that but somehow i
thought what i didn't realize is that
okay so he goes after the pawn somehow i
thought
lex king would experience trouble what
nihal is trying to do is go perhaps
bishop c through rook b1
rook v1 yup and takes b7 what's
is oh but maybe queen a2 rook d8 maybe
something like this this is that i can
always plug my knife
yeah plunk it in there yeah this is this
is happening
and black has no means of stopping it
thanks to the c4e4 bind
he does it yeah i mean i think
this has been a successful happen don't
go queen a3 because of bishop b4
the black choices are limited i think to
queen a4 and 2.82
wait a minute queen a2 the queen is
almost trapped i was thinking the same
thing but there is a
b2 queen there is but maybe something he
didn't like about that or he wants to
bring the queen back to c6
potentially or keep it on a4 to pressure
c4 rook fca comes to mind
true and this still is knight d5 you can
take queen take c4 so it plays rook to
b8 okay trying to get the rook out of
the picture
and you can bring the other rook to
defend but you have to watch out for
your back rank you do
it's not like you're going to checkmate
it just you don't want to uh
allow black's forces in and then one
important thing here is even if that
pawn on b7 had remained
if this knight is traded off on d5 you
get this protected pass pawn there
that's just a big problem for black to
deal with
for the rest of the game i love me a
protected pass pawn another thing to
deal with uh that pawn on a6 that is an
outside passer so you want to be careful
about treating too many pieces
for whites that's very far in the future
but this is something i've actually
learned from you
uh grandmaster hess is forecasting
you know constantly what will happen in
an end game what will happen upon end
game
what will happen in the event of a
liquidation and that pawn on a6
it may seem insignificant but it could
bring black some sort of advantage of
course
uh i like nihal's position here if he
can consider knight d5
he can also bring his rook in via d1
okay
well we both like the position
dynamically for white but i'm with you
that
the long term like if you just deal with
your king the king looks very safe
on shape but with a knight on d5 you
always have to look out for that the
bishop on c3 also trying to stare
through the pawn on e5 to the
g7 square so if the king gets safe you
don't have to
be alert for tactics and forks then this
a pawn down line is
certainly a useful pawn it's kind of
weak at the moment
but in the future it could be yeah yeah
exactly
um and where there's positional chess uh
you have to speak in a russian accent
it makes me sound like i actually know
what i'm talking about which i usually
don't
for the record now definitely do you
just you know don't be so hard on what's
up
thank you well queen a3 it seems like
saranac knows what he's talking about
and what he's playing about because
bishop takes d5 is now a threat winning
the bishop
obviously nihal sees that he's thinking
about how to defend against it rook a1
comes to mind
then maybe queen c5 check that's what
concerns me and probably him
something like that followed by what
bishop 65 even
yeah he plays it so if you're queen to
uh c5 there's no way to block with the
white queen because then you drop the c4
pawn right so here's the check
and the queen needs to stay protecting
this pawn so this should be 585
how do you rate that i don't know i mean
you could they and go f
that e51 is what uh impedes black from
playing knight v6 and attacking c4
immediately you could take and go f6
and the a6 is i think basically
untouchable due to the back rank
uh due to rook be one check but you give
white
connected and protected passers that's
never something to do with an easy
hearts
although it's this very kind of forcing
sequence here bishop d5 e5 rook c8 like
you're getting after this yeah f4 pawn
and interesting h6 i think that white
should respond in kind to defend this
king on h1 you could also move your
bishop away because you
would prefer to take on d5 with the c
pawn because you want your base pawn
you know you won't even protect that
pawn you want it to be
defended and easier to defend and here
after bishop d5 ed5 you're left with
this
suspicious looking c4 pawn in light of
rook c8
yeah this remind i mean it's like both
of these players are fighting a war but
h3h6 they got to eat their
sandwiches for lunch you know you gotta
eat my blt here
uh all right let's continue fighting
yeah you learned from understood very
well
you know there's uh you have to take
that bite sandwiches
the war rages on i'm just too nervous uh
when you have the opening ceremony of
the us championship
i'm finding am i going to play nakamura
in the first round or kamsky
uh and the sandwiches just don't taste
as well
[Laughter]
when you know you're going to play you
know hikaru with black or something
the next day yeah it's you know you
don't get to eat a stress-free meal
that's for sure and uh well rook b3 was
played
can we stop talking about food okay yeah
and that's where i was trying i'm gonna
have to get on doordash.com rather than
just.
this bishop on c3 is hanging thanks the
bishop takes d5 removing the guard
you can play queen of c2 but then you
drop the c4 pawn so you're just trying
to highlight
that black is immediately putting
pressure on all these squares
so white has to be alert for that and
bishop to b2 well then you're putting
your bishop still on a
square that can be attacked so is bishop
he won the move rook a5 i can see yeah
there should be one i like
but rookie rook a5 rook b1 and queen g1
maybe
and i was just gonna run my king away
but i wasn't i'm
not my not my king so i can just run it
over there no i like that idea though
you know wait do i actually care about
this hey bishop
bishop f2 yeah oh king g3 i was that we
were talking about that position
bishop f2 is the idea now yes
but you know it's not my king well it's
on g3 we're having a party though it
probably was quite bad
knight v6 now is an idea no actually i
can't find actually a check
sometimes the king paradoxically robert
is safest when it's
on a square like g3 that's what i was
claiming i don't think it's the case
in that particular variation but i'm
just trying to make a broader
accept my compliments okay i will this
time
so queen on d4 hits the rook on a1 if
that rook takes on a6 there is that rook
b
there's still rook b1 there is and i
guess
rook d2 is the queen a1
he's got to go king h2 maybe our
favorite move and he does
and thankfully for nihal he's bishop f2
which hits the queen and defends these
squares on the first rank so
i'm starting to like his position i'm
starting to really think that he's the
one
pressing the knight on d7 is dominated
by this knight on d5 and if you ever
take as we've
talked about many many times now just cd
and that's a
pass pawn yeah there's some mutually
assured destruction
in regards to these two past spawns they
can both disappear from the board and if
they do
uh there might be a draw but their
position can still be full of life i
mean
if the queens come off the board and the
pawns come off the board okay i think
it's going to be a dead draw
but uh we'll see how this is handled so
he takes on a6
so take on c4 with the queen and then
yeah
feels like that but white is like a
little faster maybe
a little pull yes okay some pressure
okay but
no but it's not i don't think it's
serious pressure i think
uh in surnagan he's got that 30-second
advantage and
we talked about this last match it might
not seem significant but it allows him
uh to generate accurate defenses and
when necessary pose a lot of problems
that if fate comes to mind as a
possibility here
i know that looks very artificial but
you want to go f6 and like king f7
yeah he goes king ffa oh so bishop
before it does not work because the
bishop
well that's actually just mass trade
right
it's like we just take and take and you
take my bishop you should g3 maybe but
okay this is all very symbolic pressure
he goes for it so you can't play f6
don't hang your bishop that would be
silly wait why not oh just kidding
uh there's actually it looks like it
should be five
oh that would be oh that was hanging
bishop if i was hanging directly because
the background
instead we see some trades and e5 is
hanging so rooksy five
always able to generate some you know
some pressure but i think this is all
very
easily resolvable and do we have don't
don't walk your king onto the dark
square king seven yeah yeah that would
be
foolish yeah um
so king b7 bishop before we're gonna say
rook training
[Music]
but here's the thing that e5 font being
on a dark square is what really hurts
black because you plant a bishop on g7
there
and you're never entirely sure that it's
a draw true
and f6 has the same problem with b7
check you'd be forced to play rook c7 i
take and bishop of fate at the end so
look at this
he's already crazy he's able to rook c2
i would go rook c2
for full activity no but there's bishop
f8 there oh anyway
yeah i'm just going to pull my bishop on
my face this is okay serrano's going to
move got him one second
oh my gosh he goes for the end game but
wait a minute he might lose two pounds
it's a great call robert
you know having f5 is what he's gonna go
for he's gonna go for a five
oh no he gives this one up i don't like
that king h king g three king h working
g5
isn't the king just and then well bishop
e8
okay this is really hard to defend with
seconds in your clock but what is
white's plan of improvement
i would watch h47 he should he wants the
g4
but do not take do not take this pawn on
g4 yeah yeah yeah because that allows
the passer but first i would make the
improvements exactly oh king of faces
yeah that is incredible
how did he do that he's just he just
posed you you said about sorry no
problem
has more time right when he has more
time he's the one posing these little
problems but this is what nihal did in
this game is
he was the opportunist he said hey
you're pawn on g7 you're pawning h6
dark squares my bishop is too powerful
on h7
this is it wow and you never say never
you
spot the smallest uh deficiencies in
your opponent's position that's exactly
what modern chess is
and uh that that's that's just flat out
impressive with almost no time on the
clock
yeah just one of those positions from
black's point of view in that game
where you know you should hold the draw
that you you know for certain
but you're like wait push my face that
scares me and then he plays that move f6
and forcing the rooks off the board and
then he loses one pawn then he doesn't
have enough time to figure out the exact
proper defensive maneuvers so here we
have a new game
sorry now with the white pieces i once
again prefer his position
but we are still pretty early on he has
the
fianchetto bishop the more advanced
position however
this bishop on a6 is always annoying it
always is it's pesky it's pressuring c4
and i was just going to say a book could
be
written about the end games only the end
games in the jscc robert i mean we've
been treated to some
incredible displays both in terms of
defending and attacking
and yeah i mean what to make of this
position well knight takes d5 always has
to be reckoned with that's an idea in
such positions
i i mean i it has to be considered even
here but ed bishop d5
95 i don't like i feel like nihal has
stabilized the boat here but
it's never entirely equal uh it might be
equal
objectively but what i wanted to say is
there's always some intrigue when it
comes to the queen side things could
happen there on the c file
yeah and also because white spawns on b3
which is somewhat atypical of these
sort of exchange slav type of positions
the black queen can actually start
making progress here and the bishop on
a6 is well placed
earlier on you're like with the bishop
on a6 is that really where it wants to
be
but the answer is yes because there's no
knight b5 and it's harder for white to
make inroads here and
actually this looks completely yeah um
symmetrical
but yeah i was trying to build it up i
do think that black
can play a little bit here i mean
because of the dark squares i think that
what
black has the light squares under
control whereas
exactly move like queen before could be
a bit frustrating
yeah i was considering queen before
you've always got to watch watch out for
knight takes d5 for example
but yeah queen takes d2 that clearly
doesn't work right
so question after queen before is how do
you actually improve the position
uh let's say white simply passes the
move like king g2 or something
what is blocks do you see anything for
black there that's the essential
question that's what we're trying to do
that's a king g2 like how do i pilot
more pressure
but i think that there will be a knight
e4 jump because you take with the knight
typically that would be good for white
because your knight oh i stole a piece
you know i get your queen back
but the c2 rook is hanging so there will
be knight e4 type of jumps because of
all the pressure down the c file
so i actually think that queen 4 is a
very direct threat
of knight e4 because the bishop takes
pawn takes in comes this bishop to d3
and
well thank you for all the squares on
the board indeed that was very well
explained and i think okay kg2 kg7
the sandwiches the blt's gotta get the
reuben
okay let's keep fighting down the c file
why can't move his knight also away from
c3 that's not impossible
i think that's the smartest thing to do
because queen before can get
you under some trouble some pressure
there so i think moving the knight wins
making essentially this is how a frame
had done and i've heard this from
many strong grandmasters if the game is
likely going to be a draw but you can
get
uh yourself in some trouble make the
draw and we've seen many famous examples
of that where instead of just you know
forcing the pieces off and accepting
your fate
you say oh i can i can try i can try and
then oftentimes
you get yourself into more trouble than
it's worth and here trading one pair of
rooks
alleviates a lot of the pressure in the
position and i think that ultimately
we will see the players uh keep an even
game yeah and
those are some of the most sleepless
nights i've had robert in tournaments
uh when i've over pressed these kinds of
positions it's just
it's it's excruciating when when you you
know you can't get out of your own way
there's a voice in your head that says
all right time to make a draw time to
wind things down
ah you know i can press for free i can
make all these improvements
boom the game turns you know you lose a
position that
you would have never dreamed of losing
exactly and i mean the
pawn structure completely symmetrical um
there's no
weaknesses anywhere there is one thing
what is this all right knight d1
let's say rook takes you to queen b5
queen f1 but even that is
okay but the g4 square is also weak
sorry to interrupt you
no no you made a very good point that
actually this bishop on
c4 now is better than the counterpart on
f3
so i'm starting to buy that nihal's
position is looking slightly better just
easier to play and i don't see any
problems with black's
position he is i mean we mentioned his
versatility uh he's very sharp
calculationally but
what he's also very mature and obviously
as a person but
also as a player he's able to generate
these small chances and
slowly kind of twist the knife turn by
turn b5 here then g5
and you start to doubt uh the safety of
white's king and the health of his queen
side as well
yeah what i do like for sarina is this
clock mansion we're going to say this
very often and we have throughout the
jfcc but bishop b3 played by
nihal rook c7 queensland queen c3
probably should just be uh
hey that's where the scoresheets get
signed right but there's queen c4 type
possibilities where bishops before
i would not i would not trade yeah
bishop c4 b5
and here's the thing i know i would cons
okay i would say okay queen takes c3
robert why were you did why were you
saying he should play bishops before i
told you he was going to trade queens
that was the best thing
but black can still try to make a couple
of moves he's got that c4 score maybe he
sees something in the position
like 98 knight d6 hop that knight around
into c4 that would be the dream
i called this i said he would trade
queens he wouldn't go bishop supporters
through to my nickname so what what can
either side do here because
i just don't see anything 98.96
maybe f3 king death 2
like stuff like that i just doesn't seem
like it gets you anywhere
i feel like but what do you do exactly
after 98 knight d6 knight c4
do you just go a4 probably go f4 at some
point
would be an idea but you're right he's
coming to d6 into c4 like who cares with
the g5 pawn you know what else he might
be thinking about
um i don't either
i was trying to desperately okay an idea
there we go
yeah 98 felt like the move there and
so okay 96 knights before i'm trying to
think even if you get what you're
looking for
can i just push my pawn to a4 how bad is
that i think that is
has the potential to be very bad a pawn
on the light square against this light
square bishop so if this pawn gets to a4
and stuck
there then this bishop comes to c2 the
knight gets in the game
and that could actually be a big problem
right and oh you called it there
no before about it you saw the bar it
went immediately in black's favor
because we talked about it because the
e3 pawn is hanging and who cares about
g5 right knight g6
knight c4 oh man you draw the king out
and now knight c4 is gonna be a fork
how do you defend the pawn you go before
i guess but
man man man then knight e3 knight c2
robert potentially
well my big question is do you start
with a5 to cement this pawn on a light
square
or do you just keep going forward knight
c4 and then e4 as you're saying
you give yourself an isolated pawn not
good for the end game
i'm not sure this is a very tough
decision because a5
if you win that a pawn it's all but over
if you have an outside passer in this
kind of end game
you're going to win so that's a very
tempting but the problem with a5 is
after takes takes
the moment you go okay goes knight c4
yeah because you're in
93 knight c2 hits uh both
d yeah but d5 is also hanging so you've
got to take on e4 there in the middle
but you could take on e4 and then go
knight c2
exactly unbelievable man nihal's
technique
too smooth right now karpovian i mean
this is just he's squeezing out just
one little deficiency in white's
position square on c4
and the the presence of mine i think to
trade queens of course they're not going
to defend it better without a doubt
but i think he understood that there was
more to the position than met the eye
very very impressive and he brings his
bishop out take an e4 if the bishops
trade on e4 there's nice e2 at the end
still
i mean look at these pawns out here they
just have wandered
yeah it takes a knight c2 things are
things are burning there on the queen
side now if you're starting out how do
you defend this
uh you you pawn strategically but which
one you give them
yeah yeah v5 so you after knight c2 you
play id5 also possible by the way oh
that's actually
better because this f4 pawn is more
important than d4 pawn in my opinion
i agree so knight d5 if b5 you take on
f4 and now
oh and then that comes to c8 you're just
you're trying to make a
statement that once this knight gets to
c8 these pawns over here are not so good
yeah but the white black knight comes to
c3 and takes a four so 95 or 92 here
92 i would go 92 to four yeah of course
i see it
and uh then yeah knight c well it goes
knight d5 i don't think it really
matters
uh because white's gonna have to go
knight anyway i think
yeah and then you go knight c3 takes
takes
and it's it's a 50 50 game i would say
that black has excellent winning chances
there but it could also ended up drop
well the knight a4 stuck for well you
can go knight c3 knight b6 knight b5
and then there's d5 so that's actually a
pretty critical sequence that if
white is able to trade off this d-pawn
for this e-pawn these two
come off then it feels like white's
chances get
all of this 97 check come on t5 yeah
this is that one
quickly played two in 16 seconds now
what nikhil can try to do is go after
that b-pod with this game a problem
why could potentially give his knight up
for the b pawn his king will come to h5
this should be a draw this should be a
draw but it's not easy
no not easy at all because if you play
knight b4 there's like king d4 king c5
so
okay you do a count you say wait is my
king getting
here eight maybe i was thinking about
that so you can stack on b6 that seems
yeah
knight cc i'm gonna go g5 knight a8 king
c5 g5
so and then you get your king to f6
and then you the fastest you don't go
king h5 because that takes
longer and that's what nihal is thinking
about that's why he went here
yep knight doing no it doesn't work then
you take
king f4 maybe but then it's a dropping
h6 and
he's got two here move f5 played yeah
drop by agreement king h6 98 and then
take on b6 take on b5
i think they should play this out
they're not playing in a very combat i
don't know what i signed up what am i
commentating with tournament
we're taking quick draws i mean come on
this is ridiculous
well you know diana this is why you
signed up for can you guess how old
alexi
saranac is in this image oh let's see
oh i'm sorry i'm overcome
i would say eight
okay and i don't actually know just oh
no no no
no no no no i see what the producer
wants to show
my mom really likes this photo how old
do we think you are don't tell us i have
no idea you must
i actually need to remember i have a
ballpark estimate i don't know
this is this this is in my room at home
actually were you nine
i think i was nine yeah wow what a guess
let's go
amazing oh
that's so cute it's gonna make me blush
yeah this is a good photo i remember
these camps that gary kasparov would uh
would host for
for talented uh well quote unquote
talented young players
that i had the privilege of attending
that was oh come on come on this is too
much
i love it people saying dania coaching
gary right
oh man no i had that face of man 10
years from now i'll be commentating
15 years from now i'll be commentating
with robert hess
and you're like wow my life is gonna be
terrible i know that's exactly what i
was thinking gary saved me from this man
oh well look at this uh position dinah
there's a queen on c7 a rook on c1
usually the rook wins the stair down
with a queen an open line i'm looking at
knight d5 type ideas
where if you take i take and there's a
pin on the knight c6 so
bishop g5 step one let's challenge this
knight on f6
and if you are sarnan how are you
dealing with that immediate threat
uh well the question is do you deal with
it by reacting because bishop takes f6
gf yeah knight t5 i mean
he goes a6 so he forces it from the
other side
now nihal has a decision bishop f6
robert even here is possible because if
you take the other bishop
then of course white has queen g4 nasty
little move oops um
in fact winning on the spot g5 point h6
lobster pins are made
and there's no stopping it yeah well a
f6gf now what i was mentioning is that
once black's king shifts to h8 and his
rook comes to g8
i know the pawn structure looks really
bad but these positions can turn really
really quickly
i agree uh but donna one thing i'm
looking at is i hear bishop d3 but was
there an opportunity with
like a tactical sequence with knight d5
ideas anyway so if you took on c6
took on f6 was there a knight d5 here
because pawn takes politics
i have queen g4 bishop on d7 i take on i
take on c6 with the pawn
oh you took on c6 it's the pawn but then
your pawn structure looks
terrible here right like a6 is hanging
yeah but am i not up a piece there
what are you talking about oh i thought
okay we were talking about different
things
so now i'm looking at your screen i
thought you were still talking about
knight t5
no no i was immediately i got you right
i was thinking of a completely different
line
got it so bishop c6 bishop totally
innocent now oh that makes perfect sense
of course yeah no that's actually looked
like a really interesting idea
yeah now that we're on the same
wavelength if robert has had proposed
that i would have advocated for it
yeah i'm just trying to point out that
there is a pin on the bishop when c6 and
queen g4
check will hit the other bishop so it
looks like you're regaining your
sacrifice material and with interest
because there's these weak pawns
on the uh f file so we didn't see any of
that he retreated bishop to d3 which is
still probably a good thing nihal taking
the
kind of the non-tactical approach
but which is fine because he wants to
play f4 e5 and if sir and i ever play z5
himself there there isn't this
equivalency between the d45 squares
white has easier access to it than black
because black's you know the bishop the
bishop's counterpart is on d7
and not on e6 right that's a very good
point that you know it's annoying for
black because after especially after f4
you want to play e5
to stop that pawn from e4 from pushing
itself but that gives up it vacates the
defense of the d5
screen look at white's pieces the third
rank attack
these knights and bishops all are just
doing very well here you could slide the
bishop to b1
prophylactically just getting it out of
the danger zone that's not
truly necessary yet you could also okay
five
he goes for the direct approach he opens
up the bishop there are already some
sacrifices i'd be thinking about once
the rook gets to f3 on h7
right so you could swing you right to
age of a check with the queen h5 and
you can also start with bishop e4 here
keep that bishop does so safe and sound
queen h5 be careful don't do that
because of f5
good point so let's show queens of f5
hits the queen hits the bishop no
ambassador for you
exactly now is there a knight before for
you probably not because of knight takes
d4 and queen takes c1
yes that would so that rook on b5
that's an interesting idea by sarna
right he's trying to change the course
of the game he's trying to get me hulk
to think
uh and i would still consider going rook
f3 here just continuing with my king
side strap she goes king h1
stepping away for the time being he
wants to go knight d4
your idea spoke volumes to him because
now knight d4 even though you're queen
on e2 under attack
it's not under attack with check so
knight takes
rook c7 92 before would have checked
your king on g1
now you take the queen i take the rook
and thank you for at least an extra
exchange and probably more
coming out indeed at 94 rook c5 there's
knight takes e6
so i mean where does black even go at
rook before
rook a5 but that is not a movie you play
you know if
you're in love with your position no
certainly not so knight d4 just
challenges black
immediately to come up with a couple
moves that
save the day but the first move is
probably the easier one like rook a5 for
example
is after that like how do you continue
to fend off what is
mounting pressure i would play a3 you
could sort of yep
he plays slowly and uh there's nothing
wrong with that it's very hard for black
to even make a move here i
agree i would i would start thinking
about sacrifices along the lines of f5
right not also that rook on
uh and f5 we're just trying to break
open the position but we do acknowledge
the e5 pawn is
hanging we're talking kind of just as
ideas even if the ideas don't work in
the immediate position it's good to have
them store them
figure out later yep yeah i know i think
queen d1
but then we can come back to a5 and i
cannot quite fly into the crushing
can you just take on c6 down here and
just like get a better pawn structure
you absolutely can
and perhaps you should like knight c
bishop c6
takes pawn takes and you're right your
pawn is here so you have
a weak queen side but something tells me
that's not the most that i can squeeze
out of the position what
neil has to be very careful about is not
to obviously not to take too much time
here goes queen c2
okay now rook a5 what is this idea is
rook i5 even forced i think it is
and then you go
quite see it i want to go to knight b3
but then your work goes to like
b5 somehow serena holds this together
you could go queen b3 and again you can
take on c6 as you proposed
uh at the right moment queen b3 will
threaten bishop b6 after that by the way
true so you know rookie rook a5 queen b3
trying to get the bishop to the b6
square and there's 96 sacrifices that
at some point yeah and again he's got
the threat of knight
c6 or even potentially e6 and bishop b6
all right how do you say square on v6
how do you see rook a4 is one idea yeah
you might have to play rook a4 but
bishop c bishop c2 rook c4 okay
wow barely escaping barely but
he does it and you could double on the
sea follow if you're knee hall you could
add some
spice with rook c3 potentially
but then the queen drops away from the c
file you start feeling
yeah one gets the sense that's not the
most that i could do
right but you want to be practical
in regards to your clock also yeah i'm
like really trying to find that knockout
bishop f3 so he can move his knight
without dropping his bishop on
e4 and the only place he could have
moved was to c6 which would have been
fine
but now he can move his knight elsewhere
and continue to go after this rook on a4
right but i like the move queen b8
finally solving the problem of the pin
uh the knight on c6 can now move it
might be time for nihal to say all right
i'm going to take on c6 i'm going to
relinquish
uh the the rook from my clutches but no
he goes knight v3
now there is a positional component to
this idea if he goes knight c5
uh he he may potentially force the trade
and those dark squares around black's
game ooh
yeah not good bishop a7 bishop was the
first one that came to my mind
you just go queen a8 and it's uh not
that yeah exactly knight c5 maybe should
be preferred
nice i don't know about what knee haul
is doing i mean maybe it'll backfire but
i guess we'll see in the next couple of
moves
yeah this is well the f4 pawn is also a
little tender actually so if you play
knight c5
maybe he'll just take you on c5 and win
your f4 pawn so the rook on yeah that
was on b5 and a5 and a4 it's
doing a good job so i would play knight
d2 perhaps
because this configuration with rook a4
knight to a5
it's sort of offside looks kind of
questionable
so keeping the pieces on the board he
plays it but after taking on c8
honestly i'm trying to figure out the
same thing because he gives black a c
file
c2 bishop d1 i mean it's that's what he
wanted to play bishop d1 and with his
rook on c1 he couldn't do that
oh that makes sense because it would
have been hanging
yeah so he could play bishop d1 the rook
goes to a5 knight to c4 for example
looks really nice e4 also wait that wins
the exchange
yeah rook five minutes oh my goodness
wait but rook b5 bishop bishop b4 and
then
rook d5 there's knight b6 amazing he got
to the rook at last
it took a while but he did but he got to
it eventually
and that b6 square it's killed black
first the bishop threatened to appear
there and now the knight threatens to
appear there
and serenade loses the exchange he's got
to give it up in the most strategic way
maybe drop his knight back to d8 for
example try to take on b5 with the
bishop
but at that point there's knight b6 with
tempo if knee hall even wants to unpin
his knight which he doesn't have to you
play b3
exactly or we're c1 and b3 some kind of
yeah exactly
combination of moves this is losing whoa
whoa
what's happening if this one if i take
it and [ __ ] knight b6
and knight b and mb6 looks good i mean
quincy two no quizzy two i just take b
yeah
no there's nothing i'm just trying to
figure out i mean queen d
you have to give up the piece i think
and go go after
okay queen c6 rook c1 even there was
possible i i think it was smart by
sarna all things knight p3 his position
was losing right
it's been lost but this way at least you
know in seven seconds for white you need
to figure things out so bishop takes b4
which is a great move actually yes
making everything safe
now knight c896 is a maneuver that comes
to mind you've got to do something with
your knife you've also got to do
something he's got three seconds
oh a nice move pinning the knight just
you crazy we're trying
okay queen is you could put a three at
some point five ninety six okay he's
gotta push his pawns but he's gotta
watch his king also discern uh
that's easier said than done he's got no
pieces to do it with and this should
just be
absolutely frustrating yeah yeah yeah
queen b7 uh he's gotta be
home yeah he barely got that move off
seconds he's got oh my gosh he really on
my lap
he's got a premium there we go he just
played
any move yeah and so to start up bishop
d4
and you can trade queens go g4 f5 yes
you can
why yeah five wins and takes f6 before
f7 he promotes
in time
yeah what a game wow he almost lost some
time though he made him that was
pointless
six seconds yeah i was i mean when you
see that clock
dipping below a second i that's where i
start just
getting really nervous and that
worries me for sure but if you're a
nihal sauron fan you're like well i mean
he is a
another bullet yeah just knows what he's
doing casual bullet scramble
and nihal getting out to the fast start
in the longer time patrols that
does spell big trouble for alexis
sarnath because
sarnath won his match against jeffrey
in the longer time patrols what's up
sorry i was
this is theory but if you go back to
move 11 i thought knight h4 won the
queen
but then i remembered it is a line
because of knight takes d4
right so you sorry i just i not every
day you see the queen getting five of
ten that's why i
excited no it's good good to keep an eye
on that because
you can mix up your lines and then that
would actually trap the queen
so instead we see black castle
fully developed the bishop on c8 not
exactly the
best piece in the world but white has
these issues on
the king side you played g4 but you're
not getting an attack and so maybe that
created more weak squares than it was
right something like e5 comes to mind
now in reference to your point
about the five minute segment going knee
hall's way
uh you know i think saranas playing
decently i don't think he's showing
necessarily bad
form um but with that being said what
negal is doing so well is exploiting
small advantages we saw this game after
game first at c5 square
then that rook which was misplaced but
he thought to
persistently try to trap it and
eventually he succeeded
and this ability to capitalize on small
advantages is
um well it's the hallmark of an
incredibly talented player and
uh sir now is going to have to tighten
up his play a little bit
if he is to right the ship here yeah he
does
and you know this position the two
bishops
there's potential here that's what we're
going to talk about that white has
long-term potential and black if you
just sit and do nothing
then the advantage for white will
increase because moves like rook c1
eventually trying to play e4
that's all going to be nice for white
the knight and c6 is kind of
stuck where it is it would love to go a5
to b3
for example but then the e5 square is
given up and you do not want to see that
white nightland there with the bishop on
g2 opening up so i do believe
that white holds the advantages in this
position
and i'm not quite certain maybe you can
tell me what should black's
strategy be in the next bunch of moves i
would go for
for some sort of sacrifice e5 d e knight
f4 i would do it here i would do it in
like four seconds i'd play e5
and again because i love sacrificing
other people's pieces i know
nihal style can be sometimes more
measured than that but i would
i would not be able to resist i'm going
to tell you that right now i would go e5
here
so i'm just going to point out that
dania is trying to take advantage of the
rook staring down the queen
so in the event of e5 if you take with
the pawn or the knight let's say we
trade knights and you go knight f4
this is a little bit different and
that's why i took with the knight on e5
so i gave my bishop a square
but don just pointing out that the
bishop on d2 is pinned
to the queen on d1 and thus black has a
ton of counter play for the second right
and i'm not pretending like black isn't
worse he's worse
but you have to identify the moments the
other idea that i thought was rook a6
rook b6 but
that seems a little bit more artificial
to me you have to identify a moment when
okay you tell yourself i'm going to
change the course of the game i'm going
to make my opponent sweat a little bit
but with this time disparity if he hull
sort of just hunkers down
i don't see this going well for him at
all but if he plays
e5 with the time difference that we
see right now i mean it just feels like
that also yeah and
i do want to point out once more that
taking with the knight on e5 for what is
important because
after e5 d e knight f4 now my bishop on
g2 doesn't have anywhere to go
so that's a huge problem that the bishop
on d2 is pinned otherwise it was the
queen
and the bishop g would have to go back
to f1 if you're going to keep it
that's why i'm taking with the knight on
e5 if e5 is indeed played
right that's that's a great point and
with every passing second things are
getting more concerning for niall he's
two and a half minutes down the clock
and
you you said it robert okay he goes
bishop d7 he was definitely considering
e5 for i would say the entirety of this
time
yes but now that he's played bishop b7
it's so clear that white
yeah that's an admission that things
have gone very wrong in the opening he's
probably going to put his bishop on ea
we we know how good nihal is holding
these positions together
he's going to be very hard to bring down
but with this time disparity we also
know that sarnath
is a monster in terms of posing problems
uh in opponent's time pressure in this
kind of position
he's good at holding these positions
from black side of things
i am not so that's why as a commentator
i'm kind of like looking at this
and if i this were a classical game of
chess i'd be sitting there
my head in my hands completely miserable
i can't do anything and i have to be
worried is e4 coming right now or wait
not yet it's just e3 then after e3 it
can just build it up and how can i
actually create some active play for
myself
your rook a6 rook b6 idea that certainly
comes to mind and i think that's what
nihal will need to do
if he is going to avoid being just
grabbing
yeah f6 bishop g6 another one of these
maneuvers to slightly
enliven his position he goes f6
i would even think about the exchange
stack on c6 absolutely
uh and and that seems like a very
interesting idea
but at least that unbalances the
position black's goal here
is to breathe some doubt into white's uh
into sorana's mind about his capacity to
win this game e5
by the way still exists maybe not here i
mean that creates so many weaknesses
97 okay
yeah actually i do like that this bishop
on e4 though that went from c8 to d7 to
e8 to g6 to e4
got him in a diamond shape yeah rhomboid
a very french-like idea
and hey c6 okay so what does he
accomplish he traded the bishops
definitely in black's favor
sarnath getting his knight i think to d3
okay and then what well you tell me
robert
i'm trying to figure that out because i
still like white's position i just don't
know how to make process because e4
yeah we did now the knight can come to
b5 those knights in this kind of close
position robert
are very jumpy you know they can all of
a sudden put tremendous pressure on a
pawn
i like the way things are going here for
nihal
and the f4 square is under control
thanks to
oh miss wait a minute nice you could
second exchange here and go
nah that doesn't work because the rook
penetrates the a7
so i would go rook d7 but then maybe
takes in d5
that's not good yeah the 997 actually is
well positioned to meet d5
as they protect c6 so you don't have to
shatter your own pawnshop shirt this
pawn a4 though dania
that's one that may have extended a
little bit too far
but so is this pawn on d4 now that the e
pawn has pushed
there's two ideas one is g5 knight g6
knight f4
and the other is knight c8 knight t6 and
i this idea of putting as soon as the
knight appears on f4
boy oh boy is there going to be trouble
for white potentially i would go g5 here
i would also play g5 because do you yeah
you do need g5 because you play knight
g6 right away king g3 and then
wait yeah i want to get to f4 but i
can't you want to secure that square for
yourself now why can
g5 white can protect that square with
his knight
but that would mean uh making the knight
more passive
let's say on g2 yeah not good not not
what you want
so what is knee hall thinking about here
well there's other moves you can double
on the d
file but i would go for active defense
okay he does double on the d file yeah
the a4 pawn
is hanging immediately so you can take
that but you'll lose d4 so what was
yours
oh that's a problem for sure
knight c2 maybe should be preferred but
then you go yeah exactly that's exactly
the kind of sound i would e5 even
stack that up on an a4 and get that e5
here and get that knight c4 e5
yeah e5 looks very good and actually
after d e you can throw in b5 if you
really want
right okay
this is where 45 but i guess you can go
right now no dinah this is where the
time
is very important because nihal doesn't
enough time to start calculating things
like pushing the pawn to b5 what are the
consequences i'm not sure why he didn't
target that at four square honestly it
seems like he doesn't have it in his
sights
and i feel like this by and large let's
alexi off the hook here
but still even he puts his knight on b5
this makes perfect sense as well of
course
yeah but the rook on eight tied to the
defense of the a4 pawn so it's a
frustrating position of your knee haul
when you have 20 seconds left you're
like do i play c5 do i play e5
you can't play c5 19 can i play e5 no i
don't want that
exactly he's just he's not quite coming
up with a clear plan b5 knight c4
is not going to happen because his
knight can always go to e3 so you want
to look where the outposts are
and then for from serrano's point of
view you're trying to stop that like you
said
the f4 square the c4 score on the other
side of the board is one you want to
keep that knight out back as well
and here comes knight e3 improving the
position and knight be fighting with d5
so don't
yep do that d5 still possible he's
starting to take the air out of
box coordination here d5 maybe e
yeah f4 as well just like just push
these things
yep and then king can slide over to f3
and protect e4 if necessary
the all keeps shifting the knight you
could go rook c4 rook c4 then rook d8
because if you take on a4 that's a good
call h4 so he does something similar to
what he said driving the pawn to h5 but
here comes the whole attacking the fun
okay so knight c2 um and then maybe
nah that's too much i would still go e5
there i mean
that idea still exists knight c2 e5 and
try to get that knight over to f4
i completely agree but i think he's he's
not quite
certain that it will work in his favor
and with no time he can't
figure out his labor gate oh we played
b5 okay good e3
that was a good move build e5
i mean this idea has existed for all you
he goes g5 now h5 is possible covering
that square but it likes he takes it he
wants the tempo
and he wants the h file and he gets it
then i can't move without dropping c6
rook a7 maybe get the rook around he
defends c6 instead
so there's some e5 could be a timely
shot to kick the rook away from the
defensive c6 one the knight is covering
for now
but if the knight moves away then e5
could be an idea but i just don't see
the exact sequence that takes advantage
so knight b4 is also an idea just to go
right after c6 and give up d4 but that
should be
uh liquidation right and he's sort of
waiting for that to happen so we're not
poking and prodding six seconds to the
clock with two a minute
uh alexi okay he goes knight v4 there we
go
now what are we going to see here white
is definitely the one playing here
for a win especially with two seconds
what does black dude does he do a pair
of rooks
e5 oh rookie rookie take e6
yeah and then take b5 and f6 is going to
be weak this does not look good but
you also have this idea of doubling on
the second rank that's going to be a
mate threat
it will be five e5 e5 always yeah just
take on it but e5 there's still might be
rook to d2
yeah might be winning there watch out
you need to be very careful
let's meet this one b6 is winning and
serena
well is this easily winning though
because somehow white's king is boxed in
it's no this is wrong i've seen this
position before and like there you go
rookie three
yes this is a draw it's like a van well
game or something this is amazing
you're like i mean i've seen something
similar before but this is still amazing
to me
there isn't even an attempt here no
you're a rook f5 kg6 you just have no
moves
the only moves that white has king h3
king g3 you're not getting out of this
well he's got to give up e5 it seems and
you know make a couple moves there but
that's a dead draw with the pawns
arranged the way that
the way that they are other than f4
there's no attacks
yeah because rook f6 qg7 you can't push
your e pawn because it needs to
say defending this rook on f6 so this is
been seen before and it's a draw wow
that is crazy to think of this with
almost no time on the clock f4 rookie
three that's the key detail
and i think serena is coming to terms
with it right now
yeah this is this is okay
king f7 you have to make sure you don't
drop your g5 pawn that would be tragic
exactly whites yeah this is white's
really only attempt in black's time
pressure
try to get the king t i've seen this
position be lost before
uh when the king gets to e4 and somehow
makes its way to f5
right but i think the hull knows what
he's doing here yeah the problem is if
the king leaves the f3 pawn falls and
that's why you see
a rook f4 oh right four would have iced
it
right but this take on f3 now we have
yeah and rook f7
the jeep on there is just no attempts
normally if there's a
non-jeep on and you get you know okay
but now even the
six ranked defense yeah exactly so if g6
is played then you bring your rook to a
once you
yeah with with the pawn on the g5 you
can even keep your rook on the eighth
rank which is something is a big no-no
normally in the end game yes but i think
it's important for everyone to know that
you often want to put your rook behind
but you want to wait kind of
counterintuitively you want to wait
until the pawn gets the sixth rank i'll
show that
uh when this game concludes just because
i think it's a very important endgame
lesson for people to see
so let me show that uh i bring up the
analysis board
and at the end here before g6 is played
like let's say you play rook to b1
then white has his king h6 movement
you're right don you always have the
eighth ranked defense
but i think just people like to give a
check from behind but then the king
enters this position
with a checkmating threat and so i force
your king
out from the opposition and then i will
be able to push my pawn and win so king
f8
check you here kg7 i push my pawn i
build the bridge
and i win the game right uh
if you check back from here then there's
g6 you need to know that you have this
eighth ranked defense it comes in
kind of obviously at this point because
if you stop checkmate but
you just want to wait until the pawn
pushes and then get the rook behind
that's uh the essential lessons let's go
to the
live board because they're blitzing
things out here they both have about
five minutes with 17. so they're deep
in theoretical waters right and we saw
in in
alexis previous match jeffrey struggled
for this a little bit he would get some
promising positions
and he would falter in in critical
moments when when he had a chance for an
advantage and now we see alexia i think
in some regards
uh and in large part due to nihal's
resilience and his ability to generate
uh incredible defensive chances that
previous game really hurts robert
yes it did because yeah just were points
where it felt like sauron was making
progress and he was right he got to a
position where he was
up two pawns in a rook end game and yet
couldn't win based on the uh position
that's something that's extremely
frustrating but i don't think
sarna does he really get that tilted
no i think he's well he's anybody who
makes it this far in the jscc
possesses a incredible set of qualities
period and one of them i think is
inevitably the ability to stay
level-headed
in times of of trouble and uh it would
be an interesting statistic to see
how many times both of these players
have been trailing
in their jscc matches maybe something
that will look up over the break but
both of them are incredibly level-headed
and very hard to
sort of psychologically unsettle well
diane they have been trailing it
certainly wasn't
in their semi-final match-ups because
they both won yeah
one-sided affairs even though the end
score for sauron versus jeffrey was like
three
maybe but it's because jeffrey started
winning a bunch of bullet games and
before that
uh alexis was out and leading speaking
of out in the lead this pawn on d6
that's a passer that you're going to
struggle to fend off because the bishop
on b3 is an attacking piece
the pawn on d6 is a nice weapon and
you just pass bomb that's hard to gain
yeah it is a pass pawn
and uh this is a very interesting type
of position where
black's also got to watch out for the
safety of this king because in
the effort to stop the past one i've
seen many games where black neglects
uh to keep his king safe and there's
some sort of back rank idea
now i think objectively this game should
probably end in a
well i don't know queen b7 rook d7
i'm trying to think in that position and
queen of fate is possible oh that's
nasty no this is nasty oh and i can also
say bishop a4 i've already protected my
d6 pawns
right and just push oh yeah you can
because the queen from v8 is protecting
it
that's just game over actually and he
does wait so after queen
after queen b7 what do you even do look
at fate
ah come on man
that was the first move i said and i
have to admit like when i said queen f8
that was my idea of
going for f7 and protecting d6 but then
i looked at the
uh evaluation bar off the side and queen
f8 doesn't look here let's go back one
move
plus 3.74 okay queen of fate is a move
that looks good it's not plus 3.74
right 94 is a great defensive resource
by saranac targeting white's king queen
takes f2 is a big threat
whoa whoa actually overlook yeah
and now this thing's turning around
completely don't they
yeah having that bar though man that's
just imagine if the players at a bar
you said plus 3.7 you immediately find
bishop right exactly it's one of those
things
you know you hear it you're like okay
there's a there's a crushing blow
uh and then your brain primes you and
guides you into finding it
unbelievable the move 94 i think what's
hard to see
is how suddenly black poses threats
against white's king you know you're
dominating you're threatening black skin
all of a sudden
queen takes f2 huge threat gotta attend
to that play rook f1
sad necessity i think yeah rook foreign
do you have something like queen e8
oh i like that king h1 i don't have no
idea
wait but that's really fascinating
because the rook on e8 needs a defender
right so dania's ideas of queen f2 king
h1 like you can give a check
but then when i go k2 you still have
this well there's perpetual queen f4 i
think you can give the rook and go 92
but you're not going to get more for
more than perpetual out of that
discovery he does it
wow queen aid's a huge move to find
there
because knight takes f2 what's happening
there like there's a discovery
rook d5 maybe oh that's a
the knight you take the hits and you say
i'm gonna go after that
so don is saying rook to d5 hitting the
queen knight h3 is a
double check it's not often you allow a
double check and still uh are the side
that's happy
but queen g1 just one check thank you
for your night and
well good night right let's see what you
did there
but if you make one more of those funds
i might exit the tournament
yeah so queen f2 your laugh
covered up my fun actually i said if you
make one of those one more of those ones
i might have to exit the tournament he
hall
rather than commentating i made this
come i made this one last time so i
won't do it now
uh anyways let's get back to the game um
and
so why is this so okay for white because
you've lost a pawn
your king on h1 doesn't feel the same
sound is it just the claim that this d6
pawn
is full compensation because i see the
bars as
zeros and i look at the position i'm
like i don't really see why this is full
of quality
it's the kind of zeros though that could
turn either way white could either
easily lose that pawn
or black could allow it to move to d7 i
could see this turning either way i feel
like it's dynamic equality
by black maybe and there might be a take
take bishop a4 again
that you have to watch out for because
then i can push my pawn to d7 so queen
c5
if i trade but bishop a4 rook d7
like if you ever capture on d7 you're
walking into a pin so i'll have a move
like rook c1 to go after
your pawns so the black king can end up
running into e7
the white rook will probably take some
pawns and maybe that's
just what is needed for white to survive
and here's a6 sort of a level-headed
move just making some small improvements
and preparing b5 against bishop a4
that's true
although i'm sorry i like this d6 pawn
again for a moment i was worried about
white's king but
white king's not really in true games
safe now
but what exactly does white do here i
mean it's the kind of position
rook c1 bishop c2 seems a little bit
artificial that came to my mind though
okay actually that actually doesn't look
that bad for me because it also
threatens some rook c7 concepts
the one thing that concerns me well
there's a couple of things one is the b3
bishop is undefended now
might seem insignificant but that's
something to keep an eye on
oh between c5 maybe you take and go a5
and fix that pawn on a light square i
like that
for sure the pawn a6 is not very happy
to be there but there's knight e8 or
bishop c4 i don't know yeah rook takes
d6 you take twice
c4 and then knight my man after
knight e43 knight f2 check so you have
to be very careful
oh come on you faked me out
you thought i was going for the d6 pawn
but no no i was thinking i played bishop
c4
please do that i'm not going to because
i was seeing that knight on e8 i thought
yeah i thought you win 98.
oh okay goddess 98 bishop c4 you're not
allowed to play 94 that's two that's too
aggressive
sorry sorry my friend even though this
probably still is going to be a
good position for black likes kind of c4
indeed
and so we're not taking his time now as
he should he can go a5
and fix the buns that would not be a
good move yielding the b5 square
then bishop c4 yeah a5 bishop c4
get that bishop to b5 that's kind of an
outpost for that piece
too good to be true yeah so
it's a big decision here to be made it's
a very sort of amorphous position robert
it's hard to make heads or tails of
exactly what you do here and this queen
enough to sort of need to stay here
because queen f5 check will also be
annoying right like if your queen is
gone i
get this check you can't play g6 because
your knight would be under attack
right so just feels tougher for black to
play
even if black is better let's say that's
the objective evaluation
i just don't see an easy move yeah it's
it's it's not zoom spine but
i say that you know with a smile on my
face but okay queen h2o that is a very
bold move
we'd have five check and be met with g6
but
something about this move seems a little
bit concerning but nihal has only 27
seconds to figure out what that is
maybe bishop c2 check bishop c2 there's
still
g6 and the king the king doesn't want to
go to g7 that's
where does the queen go g5 yeah it has
to but then wait a second we see a
bishop c2 track
yeah i don't really want to trade queens
that queen f2 your idea
then rook have four maybe now bishops do
g6 i guess he takes
okay so this is f7 is possible and so is
bishop so
yep but bishop a6 i feel like black is
squarely playing for a win
in green he goes for this and there's no
ns
there's no mate along this floor because
of the font on g5
yep takes d6 is black pressing here
probably slightly better has to be right
but the point is rook d6 you can't take
on e8 because your rook's under attack
so that uh rook g4 a nice move to win a
pawn at least
in the knight six though crowd attacking
the bishop now bishop
b3 oh bishop b3 you can't you cannot
cannot attack the bishop because of
bishop c2
good point look at this you've got to
play rook d2
and rook g5 and you've restored material
quality
i would press of course if you're black
because before seconds when there is a
night there's trouble as we know
and rookie five there's knight c5 trying
to go 93 and then a four
type of ideas bishop c4 links the bishop
to the a6 spot now the pawn might be
lost
he's gonna move he's gonna move rookie
six check he's trying to take on b6
played down a piece
i don't know that's a very interesting
idea i think it's lost it has to be
yeah especially with no time on the
clock he goes a5 instead which
oh please take me on a5 because of
rookie six check
oh just a little tricky a little tricky
yeah he knew he was gonna lose that pawn
anyway
and this has to be a win for black right
it does
but i actually once drew a similar
position over the board against
bouchon g chinese grandmaster and i had
a i had a bishop but
it was one of those like two pawns
against one situation you think he has
to be winning
but with a knight the knight can chisel
its way into
white's position here with well maybe
you can even take here i think
yeah there could be a rook swap and then
you bring the king in but he's doing it
this way there could be a meeting next
to me sure like could there be like some
kind of king h4 knight g3
type of mating out as well too much to
ask for
yeah also you're gonna have to watch for
stalemate ideas if you put a king
king on h4 knight on g3 that is in
effect stalemates white's pawns
true okay so he's using his knight as a
cover the one thing you have to watch
out for if you're
black isn't obviously not to lose that
g-pawn
oh we train no what happens here
this is gotta be losing king f5 so king
of five kh for this king
f4 yeah yeah and then g4
g5 and 94. you really want white to push
the pawns because
g5 you would or would not i would
okay sorry i interrupted you no no i'm
just gonna say that
you okay this is what you want for uh
sorry not as soon as you push the pawns
they become weaker the pawn g2 is very
hard to get to
the pawn on g4 is extremely easy to get
so look the king's already boxed out
g5 and g5 it's it's over i mean that
knight easily limits the pawn and it
zooms along and it's over
and that's a that's a big game big game
for alexi with the black pieces
as they enter the last game of the five
minute segment
wow we've already been here for almost
an hour and a half that's crazy i feel
like it's
game one these games have been so
saturated so full of life and complexity
i actually really cannot believe that
like i know the score is four to three i
see that in front of me but i feel like
we're still in like the
third game yeah i know i feel like i was
gonna say exactly the same thing i i
feel enthused and energetic and so we
have this position we've seen it before
these are the questions that we tend to
ask each other who will blink first
who's going to change their opening and
the quicker time patrols
but yeah sarna likes this position he
hasn't played g4 yet so that's a big
difference
between this game and some of the others
and because i guess he hadn't played g4
incomes
e5 as the queen defends the e5 square
right
and he's opening up the center and i
like that he's doing it much faster this
game
we saw him get in trouble once the
position gets cramped
uh you know the opportunity doesn't come
around again
and uh serrano taking the first thing
which is always a good sign for for his
opponents because
he's really known as as an opening
specialist we've discussed that
yeah the bar just went crazy three
that's what i was looking at he
that oh this knight is in trouble too
nasty no this is there this is wait
knight takes c3 queen a5 and g5
oh my gosh tonight traps is that your
claim all my lands
so it's a queen a queen of six c3
i'm going to show that real quick knight
c3 if you take on f5 i take on d1 i'm up
a piece because my bishop attacks your
knight
so bc queen a5 and g5 next move
traps the knight was over excited about
this or did not actually
win the game no you're you're totally
right then i strapped out there
yep and what he's done is also
very advantageous take steps too but at
least his gifts are not some light
but i i assure you donya that alexia
will not be repeating
this exact variation why would you think
so robert don't make him
jump to conclusions i mean this is a
very good line
i love how you're trying to say that
with a straight face
this is something that you you have that
one time mistake and you
absolutely never do it again right okay
dad cross that off the list
exactly and i i just want to see it
looked interesting i mean the e3 square
there's a knight that is replacing them
this is still so nasty and it's easy for
me to criticize and say i should have
seen this and this
but my coach would always talk about
this which he would call the narrowing
bridge
where when you're winning it's like when
you enter the bridge it's very very wide
and then the further along you go it
becomes narrower and narrower so you
want to be very careful about
being a little bit too cavalier in terms
of uh pressing on the gas pedal here you
want to win the game
uh swiftly and you want to pounce while
the iron is still hot if that makes
sense
i'm with you because if you do let this
king castle by hand or
then all of a sudden you're like wait
where'd my advantage go also
you also pollute your own mind by
thinking i was much better if not
winning
i should still be that where that may
not be the case rookie 3 is certainly a
good move
you are just shutting down white's plans
you just bring the next rook in
yeah so now it's trying to castle by
hand rook f1 king g1
problem with rook f1 is that it well
queen g6 here
is possible as a prophylactic move
against king g1 and then g4
weakens the force there's also queen h6
hitting h3
threatening knight c3 rook f5 oh no
something like that yeah very that's i
think that's a brilliant move actually
it's like queen h6 h4 i'm just chose
knight c3
politics rook f3 check and now there
would be a background checkmate
but after ef3 queen d2 is checked to
your
miserable king and this is definitely a
critical moment where nihal is i think
deciding between
these two moves also queen d6 is
possible again
uh coming at it from the other angle but
i really like the movement h6 i think it
just doesn't
end the game immediately it very well
might it could but
it just i don't know questions i feel
like your moves though are more natural
queen g6 in particular just feels
so simplistic yeah in a good way
right exactly and no you want to be some
sort of simple
and straightforward and people think
that's that's bad and every idea has to
be super complex
it doesn't you know if you play simply
sometimes
that means your idea is healthier yeah i
like queen g6 actually because the
knight can't move from f3 the g3 pawn is
hanging thinks the rook on e3
it feels like white can't really even
move
so queen g6 is just one step
of many in the right direction yeah
the one thing is well you want to play
quickly right two minutes
two minutes on the clock and i get a two
minute advantage now for alexi i know
that might be insignificant in a winning
position but
i'm looking at queen d695 you know
there's a lot of the stuff
that you're going to have to process and
you need time to do that robert
yes so for still always
crazy amount of time for alexi but not a
great position
and uh i'm just looking
here for a second once so you know we
see that
what's neon thinking about exactly
because he plays take on c3 first and
queen e7
now that is something we didn't factor
in a very positional approach he's going
after that a pawn and simultaneously
keeping an eye on the e2 pawn
we've seen two knight a5 knight c4 i
mean it we've seen his ideas
uh can can look a little bit you know
they can look like they don't carry a
punch but they almost always do
uh so i'm trying to give them the
benefit of the doubt here but queen b2
95 not a5 knight e5 i don't know
yeah i think what we're trying to
highlight is that he could have taken
that bishop once c through at any point
so taking it immediately unless you have
a very concrete plan in which case he
does to take on a3 next
it almost wouldn't be worth it but queen
b2 dino's point the knight come to a5
trying to
get to the c4 square but then you free
up the e5 square for white's knight and
that's when things get complicated
and that's when things start to turn
around especially when white is well
ahead in the clock
the funny thing is if you could capture
your own pieces after queen b2 queen
takes e3 would be checkmate
that's actually really funny queen takes
rook mate
so knight h4 played queen g5 there's
knight takes f5
what about bishop takes h3 and then
queen g5 and
[ __ ] that's too much i mean i
actually i like that was that two point
knight f5 brook afternoon
queen g5 there we had knighthood there
was rook up three anyway so actually
[Music]
and these kind of moves just might have
been good knight f5 rook f3 check you
have to take the plunge at some point
sometimes you're not going to win the
game just by you know maneuvering a lot
but i feel like this is still so good
for him
yeah i can't complain about this but
queen g5 it's going to be a winning move
now this is the more i look at this the
more i realize he actually hasn't
relinquished any of his advantage
oh bishop takes c6 knight f5
excuse me hell no knight of five for you
wow okay but knight g2 kicks the rook
away
yeah rook word wait a second
rookie four i guess and he keeps the
attack on a3 and the h3
yeah attack everywhere and you just have
full control over yeah
you didn't play g5 at some point i
wouldn't do that right now
well actually i would have considered g5
there thanks
but i like the fact that he's
establishing a pass fun he can drop the
queen to d6 and then go for c5 also
as well as obviously and the good thing
about c5 is
it brings the a pawn under the bishop's
protection
very very true it becomes a protected
pass pawn from a
long range piece so h6 is trying to look
at g5
also giving his king an escape from the
back rank not that that was needed just
yet but always good to have
always needed oh gosh g5 tempe with
knight h5
crunch not he's gonna go c5 and just
smash through the center
you mentioned double pawns being often
underestimated robert
this is another instance of that where
he can play c6 and the other pawn again
undermines the pawn on d5 no rush with
that though he goes a3 drives that pawn
through this is completely winning for
him completely winning
he's gonna have to make a couple more
accurate moves though yeah and just like
the bishop
came alive to defend the a pawn c5 to c4
will open up the queen to the defense
and then
uh make this pawn on d5 even weaker
right
white needs to somehow protect that pawn
with another pawn that's not happening
now e3 falls fall and then i think g5 is
going to come at the right moment but
he's got to watch for knight h5 if he
does play g5
i think it's still works he have rookie
2 in the end of those variations but
yes just he goes rook a4 he gets his
behind his pass pawn
there's good end game technique in this
position not sure
if it was best but how can you fault
that move anyway
no you uh you can't and and uh you know
all roads lead to rome here
but but you want to be careful about
overusing that expression in chess
sometimes you get too comfortable
and again we talked about this all of a
sudden the wind gets a little bit more
difficult but he is banking on his
a-pawn
which i think is possible so are not
doing what he can though to activate his
pieces seek counter play against flex
king
he wants an e4 e5 you get e3 to e5 in
one move he would have some serious
chances just to open up
the king but too slow yep and he goes
king h2 trying to tuck his king away
preemptively the 20 seconds is what
concerns me a little bit
uh for [ __ ] hall because if he if he
gives white any hope
wait 96 96
queen rookie 7 maybe just like i would
have tried that just because of the time
situation now he drops his queen back
and that just seems like an admission of
you know nothing's going
well for me here and for a new holiday
mission hey i probably should have
played a little bit differently in the
last couple of moves
i my advantage is still huge the bishop
on c4 protects a2
uh that's you know the essential pawn
there the rook and a1 is stuck being
passive and just defending
the square and thus how do you defend e3
rook f3
yeah queen e5 rook b8 i mean bishop
takes d5 you can even play
and there's just so many moves here we
need one yeah so
this is queen e5 right after the e3 pawn
sliding in with queen e4 rook
be b1 is a plan as well
no funny queen e3
thank you yep he's gonna i'm taking that
g5 also possible i was looking at g5
rook to ba you keep mentioning that move
too many yeah i mean there's no hurry
he's just enjoying himself here and
and you can play entirely at your
leisure why there's no counter player
okay three is going after another pawn
and if rocket feed then g5 forces the
trade of queens right
winning position so rook f3 there's g5
kicking the knight the queen e2 check to
force the queens off
yep we need four same idea but queen of
two
i guess he wants queen b1
yeah why not you can't believe he's
thinking about it he's going to play
oh my gosh he's just so that's clinical
that is very clinical she can't move
and if the queen out queen comes to g1
you take it
and then you finally go rook via rook b1
or g5 or one of a million moves
what a game here to and this opening
uncharacteristically robert
sarnot doesn't usually get in such
trouble with the white pieces out of the
opening
allowing e4 e3 you know you spotted the
tactic that may have won a pete
rookie two would have won the queen
directly but this is also good
well look at this this is just tied to
hand and foot
last breaths here rook takes d5 but
this is cosmetic even queen you can
allow queen of stuff to allow it but he
doesn't
yeah very very smart not to allow it
yeah he just shuts this down entirely
and it's over it is indeed and that
means that
he takes a 5-3 lead heading
into the time patrolling what a mistake
by sarna in this last game i mean the
opening was
really just that so questionable yes
this we've seen before
and his first i guess error if you will
was
not throwing in this g4 move because
when you get this position
if the queen's on g6 you don't have e5
you've been calling for that e5
clamoring for a time after time yeah
just allow this pawn to e3
destruction immediately responded in a
big way and uh
that's definitely a rough end for
sarnath but
he's got to put things in perspective
it's a two-point game this has been an
incredibly high level final we've gotten
everything we've asked for and then some
and i'm sure we will again in the
three-minute portion but first coffee
well i'll let you grab your coffee we'll
all take a little breather and when we
return we will have the three minute
plus one second increment portion of
this junior speed chess championship
final
brought to you by chess.com and
[Music]
chesskid.com
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we return to the junior speed chess
championship final between nihal sarin
and alexis saranac
and it was predicted that nihal sarin
would make his way
to the final and be the player that
makes his way to the speeches
championship because that's what's at
stake
in addition to the prize money as we see
the predictions brought to us by
chess goals daniel nihal sarah was
expected to beat sam sevion but
sarina knocked sevin out earlier do you
think that's going to hold up
is nihal sarin going to be our champion
well
based on the way that the five-minute
portion has gone i think there's
every reason to believe that uh he's
played incredibly but
obviously uh we've seen the kind of
displays that sauron has put on
he's not in bad form today so things
could turn around
in in an instant in a single move i
think this is going to be really close
and it's been an amazing match and
but before we have left off just a
couple more things here
yeah you know the chess goals just smart
just bringing us these predictions
it's an innovative 12-week data-driven
premium study plan to help you stay
focused and reach your goals you can use
the
coupon jscc to save 25 on your purchase
so
you use the command goals in chat enjoy
it it's a great product
but alas we are about to have liftoff in
this jscc match-up
nihal saron goes into the three-minute
portion up a couple points
in the match but alexis serrano if
anybody is capable of uh
mounting a comeback i believe he is
certainly
able to do so absolutely he is and uh
we've seen that his time management has
been more than savvy
uh and uh in the three-minute portion
nihal is going to have to modify his
strategy a little bit if he's
blitz beast obviously he knows that now
he doesn't need me telling him but
uh some of those critical moments robert
he's going to have to speed up his
decision making
slightly he will and we have a different
style of position
it is catalan like in nature because the
bishop on g2
staring down towards the queen side so
that bishop is just
generally speaking the best piece on the
board but black is captured on c4 down
now white was queen to c2
i know some lines include b5 trying to
keep this pawn others
say hey take that pawn back nothing i
can do about it i'm going to be
extra solid and that's the latter
approach by sir and i
is giving the pawn up but no this is
definitely he hasn't equalized there's
no way this is equal
this is this is a catalan dream in fact
i think this is this is quite bad for
him
normally if you give up a pawn like that
you want to get b6 bishop b7 already in
he takes the approach a very solid
approach and maybe he wants to play e5
in some
of these positions yep he does play e5
yeah
the problem that i think you and i are
kind of hinting at is that the bishop
on c8 you know it's typically not a
great piece but that's why you play e5
right open up that diagonal and there is
a pawn majority for white from the
now from the d3 h files maybe it will
transition to the e through the h files
and black has a pawn majority from the a
through the c files three on two
but black's pawns are stuck in place
they are not able to push through
because white is so
well developed here and that should
leave white with a small plus but
nihal down almost 20 seconds already yep
he is
and uh now he's deciding what to take
with uh
yeah i would take with the knight yeah i
definitely don't want that isolated pawn
i like what alexi has done here in the
last couple of moves at first i was
beginning to think robert his position
was
really dubious but now he's gone e5 i
still think he's slightly worse
and i think nihal is very good at
squeezing an advantage out of these
positions
but by and large i think there's no uh
global problems with his position
and uh speaking of problems i my coffee
is five feet away i have to get up and
get it so i'm gonna give you the wheel
for three seconds here
all right well that sounds like an issue
for sure and you saw a trade of knights
and e5 the queen comes there but look at
this queen hitting b7
so black in terms of the quality of his
pieces
doing perfectly fine in fact the bishop
is now developed it was stuck behind the
wall of pawns when it was in c8 now it's
outside
any kind of pawn chain out in the open
knight on six queen on e5 rook and d7
everything nice and solid here so dania
i see
that you're back i'm only just starting
to talk to you my friend
but oh no g4 f4 f5 i was about to say
that black
did a great job of getting out of any
danger but you walked
into a loss of a piece what did i do it
was me getting up and get getting the
coffee that's what that's what made him
blunder now does he take on g4
is that the lesser evil but that rob
that's that's not that's not nearly
enough is it
no it most certainly is not this bishop
and
that's even more precise i think up for
first in order to eliminate eliminate
those possibilities
yeah that's true because if you played
g4 earlier and the bishop was already
here the queen could come to age five
but now the queen
does not get to stay and try to be a
menacing piece on the king side here
comes g4
thank you so much for your bishop
g4 bishop takes ponzi's knight g4 i
could see how
that could scare nihal off he's wearing
an e3 and
a mating attack maybe knight f5 here
should be preferred um
he's got a minute here and i don't mean
to sound like a broken record but
again this becomes a little bit more
significant in a three-minute portion
when you have less time to begin with so
one very precise move required here i'm
thinking rook f3 is also possible
queen h4 and then well you could do
nothing you could allow queen h2
that could look could seem unthinkable
but it's not always as dangerous as it
seems
not sure though what is the most
accurate way here yeah because knight
f3 would drop the e3 pawn you don't want
to lose a third one he plays your move
knight f5
queen f6 i guess his e4 yeah but i was
afraid of g6
yeah because i was trying to go queen g3
if i had enough time but your g6 move
says not so fast
okay knight e3 simply he wants to trade
the knights oh but a queen before this
rook d1
giving up the knight and he gives the
away e5 here in fermento maybe
because you don't want to do a b2 is
what you're trying to i'm not sure about
that i'm not sold on the fact that
giving up b2 is such a bad thing i mean
you could give it up and go rook up too
sure but that is a third pawn and it is
yeah
okay it gives up b2 and i see the the
bar start sinking there so
probably yeah e5 would have been better
and now
he goes f5 see that's something like
what i was thinking he goes directly for
the attack
sorry serrano traits queens as you say
what is that three queens are gone
yeah and uh well nihal could put the
pawn on f6 that's one of the ideas that
gives him that those long he still has
something resembling an attack and now
you can't take the pawn because bishop
h3
oh nice that's a nasty idea
nihal found that very quickly you did
rooks would be in a line in the light
square so that would be bishop h3 and
actually
this is so essential to white's winning
chances creating a clear pass on
in rook f7 taking a page out of your
book the pawn on a2 is the same color as
the bishop
yes for sure and also he has determined
that that end game after the trade of
both rooks on the 7th is going to be
winning for him which i think it is
yes so and if rookie six you have that
would not be very good because rook
one takes b7 and thank you for a massive
attack oh
that is nasty so what can you so i think
you have to do
yeah i think you have to take and go
king six because the the
bishop against uh pawn's end game is the
king is going to limit
yeah easily the connected passers
black's going to end up in zuma he's
gonna have to give up both funds i don't
see that happening for black
he goes for it well amazing right i feel
like it is but maybe there's something
we're not taking into account
well okay so what in order to win
obviously the white king needs to go
after this a pawn so somehow
you know black's king can't do anything
why can you go a4 leave a bishop on e8
or
whatever wait a sec though is there a
way for me to get over here
oh and then just a you can't take my
pawns are linked
yes oh my goodness that's a great it's
an amazing
defensive idea by cernov because
anything king a3 bishop b5 the problem
for
example you can't take this pawn because
black just pushes this one all the way
through
that's amazing i mean and i've we've
seen these ideas before many times it's
like the
pawns are chained together the moment
the king takes
uh the bishop becomes overloaded with
the task of defending a2 and stopping h4
it's a draw
yeah all you do now is king b2 pawn a3
and then just go king a1 king b1
uh b2 whatever back and forth and as we
keep talking about you take on g6
you'll see exactly this play out you
give one's gonna go all the way to h1
all the way to h1 and there's the draw
wow and that
is wow that's that's
a very very strong defensive effort by
sir now that move rook f7
it was played quickly a very
understandable choice by nihal it seemed
losing but because of this very specific
idea
and robert here we have another one of
these lines
we have it once more we'll see if alexei
has learned his lesson during the break
you know checked his prep he does
include g4 now there's none of this e5
stuff very important distinction and i
do see some people saying oh you know
nihal doesn't need a you know we don't
need to worry about any house time he
doesn't need to worry about it because
of
just win with them two seconds i
actually think that the last game even
though he
didn't he of course didn't lose it but
he probably should have been given more
winning chances
than he did you know by playing rook f7
he didn't have enough time to really
calculate all the consequences
and we obviously didn't know that it was
a draw so easily serrano says yeah
actually i got this under control but
right i looked at this when i was
14 and then led by led by gary caspara
vladimir kramnik i just think that
nihal does need to leave himself a
little bit more time so he can convert
positions like that
especially because sarana is never going
to go down without a huge fight
right he never is and uh neither of
these players is now
we've seen this be before this is the
position where i propose d5
black is worse here i i mean i'm not
sure what it is neil sees
in this position maybe i mean f6
prepares e5 i suppose
what's that he did last time like his
bishop somehow came around to g6 but
that's because sarnath went queen c2
very right in that game which is
probably premature
yeah and here he goes rook c1 he turns
the dial up exchange second coming
um no probably too early sorry no
i'm interested in it i don't think it
works there's always knight f4 for black
yeah i'm definitely intrigued
okay so it as is i'm sure now but queen
c2 here is also possible something like
that but that way that gives up
on so somehow nihal concretely because
of that f4 square it seems like he's got
um pretty good chances here i have i
stand corrected
yeah something's not going right for
sarna in this opening i think he should
change it
yeah i agree and i also think you should
castle here
i think you should just he should just
move his king out of the center
oh that h4 okay so queen f7
yeah queen f7 and then
niho is also probably considering queen
e8 but i'm not sure what benefits that
contains he goes green f7
although the the bar did not like queen
of seven
oh i see the difference i see the
difference okay so with the queen on f7
white can play e4 and d5 very quickly as
just
one option with the queen on e8 you
don't get e4 in because i could take on
d4
and then your pawn e4 is pinned okay but
what about knight f4 here okay knight
takes c5 i like knight f4 i feel like
while white is still on castles
you can try to generate these chances
star now still doesn't castle
but now something tells me he's
stabilized the boat a little bit
the bishop here it's all about the
bishop heading this is good for white
yeah 100 so i'm
trying something knight to d4 to be
three true
that would be a big pain so you can play
e3 that does soften up some of your
light squares but e3
it takes away um the d4 square from that
knight
what else can we play here just worried
about alexis internet here
oh wow he's a red bar but you know
okay i was going to link that to the
emails
[Music]
are we sure about this i most definitely
am not sure about this he was knight b6
quickly
look at that d4 square crunch
i i'm shocked that he played that i am
too that is
somewhere i mean who are the positional
kappa blanca
uh vladimir kramnik they're not very
happy at this point but
um i'm going to give alexi the benefit
of the doubt here he's
uh you know he's a lot better at making
these judgments than i have so
we'll see what he does here queen c
through rook ft1 maybe maybe he's
banking on sort of the immediate
activity of his pieces
perhaps and i guess there's a knight f5
jump that could be
a little frustrating at some point but
something about this seems like it
did not go the way he wanted to you
could take on ether at any moment to get
rid of the bishop pair
but perhaps black doesn't actually have
as much as i
thought just based on initial instinct
like knight c4 it's such a good piece
but
what next right and our production team
our wonderful production team reminds us
that alexi
is the trooper that he is is playing a
match from a hotel room
uh because he's playing currently the
russian higher league which is
incredibly strong over-the-board event
actually so he's making time for this
final uh kudos to him but that could be
impacting his connection a little bit
yeah so you know the background is very
different but
yeah where's that wooden sauna wall yeah
i know think one of the same thing
the steam room he's now it's all over
the board none of that
in the background but he still looks
focused he's still
of course playing his heart out and he
just pushed his pawn to
f4 so speaking of weakening moves
it looks aggressive but it could also
leave your king on g1 extremely
vulnerable
he's demanding a lot from his thesis
here he's he's stretching his resources
thin but that could pay off
um bishop b3 nihal sticks his bishop on
another outpost
look at that knight on d4 the bishop on
b3 he can also go b6 c5 and support the
knight
i i mean all of my positional instincts
are telling me that black is in
fantastic shape here
i would certainly concur with that
bishop d3 what doesn't stop b6 c5 you
just pointed that idea out
and what is white's idea
where do you go from here yeah i mean
you're again he's created so many
weaknesses now nihol with 30 seconds or
b6
indeed played i like this idea maybe you
go e5 yup
oh so you're hoping to get an attack on
this at some point
you've done so much you might as well go
the full nine yards that bfb knight f5
ideas
well there's also a queen e4 hitting h7
and threatening queen aids you actually
have to be
careful and again the time c5 by knee
hull he ignores it
queen e4 what does knee hold want to do
their g6 but then
you're checking that looks scary there's
also they're also f5 ideas after g6 like
let me just try to crash through rookie
seven
no fear g5s maybe
g5 is there f5 is like that shuts things
down i agree
okay sometimes you can get away with
things like that but not here so knight
of three
out of three the tension is so
the position might look sort of tame it
might look balanced but it's
laden with tension filled to the brim in
eight seconds here we go
okay so he does play g6 but now now i
don't like that because it
doesn't mean we can see the position has
gotten rid of that pesky knight on d4
that
lightens his load by quite taking five
f5 is just too bad yeah i thought you
could take an e5 like
h6 though that also was available that
also didn't look good queen c 40 hall
going after white's king sir
is going going take on g6
but uh queen d4 check oh gosh oh he
takes the bishop oh he attacks the brook
wow wondered wow it's look at sorry no
he's just shaking
h6 would have been much stronger your
move because that would have threatened
checkmate
yes it would f8 and g6 we
will uh bring up the analysis board real
quick here uh but
look at the players queen c4 wow
you can't believe it you can't believe
it you can at this moment
he could take on g6 right away but queen
h6 it threatens a rook f8 mate it
threatens the pawn on g6
and maybe nihal will survive this it
just i don't see the way to
uh it looks just very dangerous yeah it
does that threat of queen fate just put
this quickly to screen on the wrong
square and yeah
immediately seizing the opportunity we
have another look at this
i am going to stay very remember that
game in serena versus john
where they had crazy theory for like 20
moves this is another one of those
vienna games
i have no clue what's going on here help
me out robert i'm just gonna go through
the moves so we can show everybody
one of these lines where bishop back to
d2 and now
sarona takes an e4 queen g4 hits the
knight hits g7
says here take my two pieces for your
rook but your king is
in the center so we get to the live
board here
oh my goodness how do we evaluate this
so let's do a quick material account two
minor pieces
and no not any bonds too many pieces for
rook that's clean so that's the exact
material imbalance
the king is on e7 not thrilled to be
there you have to keep your queen in
line with the f5 square
idea in that regard g4 following knight
five could be something
and you pick queen to g7 so why would
you remove your queen from h8 was there
some kind of
threat oh g4 g4 g queen g6
knight f5k e8 queen queen d4
yeah is g4 devastating that looks
like it's devastating what does black
even do
that could just be checkmate looks very
tempting
it does and i'm sure nihal is
calculating it
the question did sarah miss it or is he
seeing something there that we're
missing
there's probably something deeper there
there probably is
he's moving very quickly so he's for
it's a bluff and he hulk calls it i
think we're about to see let's take a
look at his face
yeah he kind of braced his eyebrows
there i think he missed it
okay but he played his responsibility
yeah maybe not
so queen d4 was played but the barge
dropped so there must have been
something that was
even better maybe rook d4 weirdly enough
like that way you hit the right
queen stays defend you can double your
rooks in the d file and
i guess the point that alexi is thinking
is hey you know what give me that check
on g7 come after me
i've got everything defended he's got
the d7
bishop defended he's got the c4 knight
defendant it seems that nihal doesn't
really have any entry points he does
probably have perpetual though sardar
could get run his king to d8 even here
i guess he can take on h5 simply and
then knight f4 knight d5 becomes an idea
practically speaking this is so hard to
play in a blitz game robert
yeah it certainly is and if black can
stabilize it's a very big if
bishop c6 will happen and then it's
white's king that can get in trouble but
that's a
very far ways away heads are gonna roll
here
and uh whose head is gonna roll
so queen g5 i'm tempted to play f4 but
then queen c5 trading the queen so i do
not want to trade queens i'm tempted to
play knight f4
justin and then knight d5 i really i
know that's a very sort of telegraphed
thing like
you know like jimmy garoppolo's football
pass that he winds up for 10 minutes and
then
throws an interception but uh knight g3
so similar kind of concept he's coming
to f5 but
there's very little the black could do
maybe queen c5 your move robert knight
five kings
king d8 how do you exactly chase that
king down which is escaping to c7
that king's really just going on a
journey though there's queen f6 check
ideas which may drop
f7 so like queens if your queen goes too
far
what a brave guy f6
a7 could even take on a seven exactly i
know that
you know i know but why not you can take
that what is shock remember alexander
i certainly do three puns queen takes a7
there is bishop c6 so you actually have
to be careful you think you're not
rocking 495 etc
i'm with you i mean i'm with you that
queen seven looks like a hanging pawn
i'm just
you have to be certain before you take
that one because
that i'm not certain it just gives black
that very needed tempo
to bring a bishop on the strong diagonal
i don't like what you're
indicating about about what i am and i'm
not certain about
i don't know if i want to compensate
with you thankfully this is the
finality of the speech championship
so what what can white do he's spending
a lot of time he's done yes
he's vacillating over there that's
exactly what he's thinking about knight
f5 is tempting as well with king f7
that's the point of f6 is actually a
brilliant move
h4 also came to mind but that actually
just sends the queen to if here he goes
but he's getting too long taking that
now he did
way too long i agree and
c6 maybe come back to d4 and then 95. oh
my goodness knight f3 i keep forgetting
about that
it just feels like you're inviting me in
it's a warm welcome to dinner thank you
so much daniel
you're welcome robert you're always
welcome but
i'm really good at ordering pizza i'm
just gonna tell you i'm serious no like
these light squares are
really an issue and we're talking about
a while but now it's two pawns
and a rook for the two miners it's less
about the material and more so about the
weak squares
how does he stop 95 that's an incredibly
devastating idea the 94
trying to get rid of the bishop i would
not take that knight that's for sure i'd
play queen
b5 maybe just throw my queen that way
queen and then queen d4 maybe but again
95.
geez keeps recurring
and then actually if you're not careful
this knight from f8 can go to g6 and the
e5 or h4 right this g4
pawn would like to go back to g3 or even
g2 to help
the white king ah maybe queen b5 he
wants a4
ah and queen takes a four queen c5 and
queen takes c4
i see you with your tactics they are
nice and sharp that was a nice tactic
though yeah that
that would be great i do think that
watch this happen
wow that would actually here if a4 here
it is
so watch this happen or queen b6 queen
b6 is probably the best just
right trade the queen's 56 queen b696
96 now oh my gosh if takes knight c8
check
i guess that also looks good yeah you
could have moved the rook away after
96 but wow i like queen b6 i got excited
there because then knight f5 check uh
wait isn't that wasn't
the night just hanging on c4
yeah wasn't what are we missing there
robert i i don't know
but here he's going to take d6 take e6
and nihal again look at the clock that
he's managing and he's just
he's impervious to it and that's made
only eight
zero noise there's no way you want to
queen e5 you only went wow unbelievable
and look at how quickly he turned this
around
this idea of a four robber to find it
with almost no time on the clock
is incredible you found it he found it
you both are
i'm sitting in my comfort zone
i was like what is rook takes e5 oh my
gosh we have to show that oh my lance
oh my gosh there was just oh my sorry
there's rook a1 and rook h1 m8 you can
stop it that's unbelievable you missed
checkmate
you did oh that's so unfortunate for him
it is it is that was a huge
chance to turn things around and we're
going to get a live
automatic response oh my goodness robert
he still has like an outside chance to
hold this game but it does but the pawns
are too strong queen c3 if two seconds
anything can happen but the queen's
gonna fork the rook on e5 yeah
queen e5 check that's it
wow he mischecked me oh
gosh my goodness and does he
i mean i don't know if he realizes it uh
it's not probably not the sort of thing
you realize in retrospect oh
my god i'm like i'm wheeling myself out
of the room here i just can't believe it
i can't believe it either
that's crazy because when you put the
bishop on c6 you have to be attuned to
these kinds of things
and it was such a it was a very natural
sacrifice because
black had two minor pieces for the queen
and so as soon as you give back some of
your extra material to make your life
easier
he unfortunately made the game lost but
you know neil he escapes it now he's up
four points and with 36 minutes left in
the three plus one
at some point sauron just has to start
winning because the bullet is
favoring neil yeah and we know nihal's
bullet is just
something out of the stuff of legend but
essentially i i've been observing in
these matches that four i think is sort
of the magic
x factor number robert it's completely
anecdotal
but i feel like uh when the lead is at
four
you win a game okay it gets manageable
you lose the lead gets
the half half a decade mark that's
pretty extensive i feel like this is the
important game and look at the odds
yes those are not favoring alexi let me
tell you
no they're not in it's because nihal's
bullet skills are
pretty much second to hikaru maybe there
are a couple other people
who can claim that they are better than
him but not many
yeah no from the onset of this match
that was the expectation they were going
to bring up the
chess goals and smart chess predictions
uh it was
nihal dominating in the one plus one the
quickest time patrol
because he's just exceptional and it was
supposed to be according to prediction
that sarana would get
out to a lead in the early stages that
has not happened so it's been all
nihal in the match i'm looking at the
live bullet rankings of the people
logged in on chess.com there's two
people ahead of nihal
in bullet he's 32.79 you want to hear
who they are
on twitch and picaro
so it's one person to account exactly
got it
that's like when uh i was watching the
uh
us team uh play the basketball
well play basketball in the olympics and
they asked the coach of uh i think spain
or something
well who's the three most dangerous
teams the spanish basketball team will
be competing against
you said there will i'll name three the
usa the united states and the u.s
hall not many who can compete with him
in bullet this is the time for
alexi to do something for sure and you
know we see in this
position right now it is even material
the king on h1 you just dropped over
there there's some ideas of rook
g1 i guess but are we really believing
in that i mean
why king h1 there well
because it's russian movie no russian
noise shifts the king away
yeah i don't like this pawn structure
it's just too many weaknesses and 94 is
possible here getting that bishop
uncontested
i know it's going to be blocked in by
the d-pawn but man if that d-pawn moves
there will be hell to pay
for sure and the special can go to c8
and wrap itself around and
actually it starts on that journey just
now but what's interesting about this
donya is the c3 pawn
the a3 pawns split over on the queen
side
and nihal doesn't go for that he said
first reroutes the bishop and watch out
for bishop a4
wouldn't exchange uh but wouldn't you go
after the c3 pawn
i would i would but i'd be a little bit
worried about the g
file g that's g5
no i know i'm kidding it's actually
probably not that bad of a move but
actually yeah it's one of those things
maybe king fade in g5 you try to turn
that on white
these ideas can be very unpleasant
psychologically you feel like man my
opponent's helping me
but you don't see the reputation now yes
white threatening bishop takes d5
probably he is
you got to be brave to take that you
really must
but that knight takes d4 bishop f5 and
if e4 takes d5
hmm okay so bishop d5
knight hd4 knight d4 cd4 bishop
so he doesn't do it again knight c5
and now i would go after that pod maybe
knight a4 rook c8
okay there's knight a4 and i guess
rooksy
one is he plays qui he's moving this
queen around he does
yeah and he all keeps moving the night
around the response
so queen takes d5 can i get away with
that bishop a4
yeah there's an exchange but again look
at the knight the queen of the dance
well the the dance doesn't look so fun
anymore for white because no it sounds
very weak it's a dance of death
especially if that knight gets the v3 of
the bishop to a4 or the knight to c3
oh my gosh we're gonna say dancing
so what to do i feel like black should
have some pres like okay can i go knight
e4
right before yeah bishop takes c4 i feel
like that's a worse version because the
queen then comes to h5
and i can't i need to get my bishop like
on the right side of this pawn chain
like i need to have my bishop on e4
and again the time situation but knight
back to a4
what about c4 can you play that we
oh yeah queen before the the queen is
defended very importantly
yeah i thought you could try that but
yeah i was thinking about some sacrifice
wait
16 seconds for black where did all the
time go
it evaporated now what exactly does
alexis do i would double on the g file
you can also take on e6 so you take with
the pawn to protect you yeah yeah yeah
you slam a rook in there but there is
you're giving up an attack on c3
oh yeah that is true and if you move the
book to g1 here also
well then white is giving up the c3
square
okay taking on d5 i guess queen t4 is a
fork look at that noticing the
undefended pieces and bishop g4 is also
in the mix
okay the wheels are coming off here for
knee hall you're right because he's
bringing the knight back to e6 but he
had to give up a couple pawns here on
the
king's side of queen takes h6 but this
is a chance
knight p3 oh but then quick before check
oh wow
good find good good realization but you
know nihal's going to he's got to fight
tooth and nail he's not
never easy to bring down i mean this
already is getting better from black
because you cannot move the rook the
other way you lose your bishop with
check
and if you take on e4 i can take with
the queen trade them off and say hey
good luck to you you can even take the
pawn but i would take the queen trade
off those points 94 is a great move
with six seconds on the clock and this
is alexi just has to find a way to win
this game
and yet a lion's share of his advantage
has just evaporated
you know it's funny i i really do think
time and time again that
nihal is in trouble and then he's always
proving me wrong that hey
yep any time more than zero seconds or
nothing but three okay he gets that move
off
and rookie one watch out for some rooks
he said c7 yeah
yeah but now c3 is not under attack at
least not the same way bro and alexa
goes that rook g8 was possible
check there's rook to check and then you
take the wow
so that's the idea animal right now and
then a b
and rook c one maybe but you're always
going to move you're obviously one
more six six be six that's three points
oh my gosh
but he's going after blight spawns white
spawns are very weak here king f3 king
g3 c
and f3 if rook c4 but then you take on
b4
oh he's just trying to give him oh this
is a really nice move
king of three and that's taking up seven
this should be winning for white now two
puns to the good oh and you're also
gonna mate this king
57
be careful don't take yeah because you
don't break a big check as king g3 but
brigade check is now the threat so he
puts his work on five you can't leave
the last round i know it sounds crazy
but you've got to always watch for
stalemate ideas
but this is fighting to the last drop of
blood is nihal but
this is winning pretty straightforwardly
yeah rookie six the pawns just pushing
themselves together and
it's winning and no reason not to spend
a couple more seconds if you're in the
hall you're up four points
every every second counts but there's
still a lot of time
but donna this is the first time that
neil's time travel has cost him because
he's been
in the midst of time scramble after time
scrambling wait a second
no this has to be winning this is a
hundred percent his wedding
check uh yeah e6 okay continue
sorry yeah you worried me i was looking
at it like wait is there any way this
isn't winning
okay and the king yeah no this is
winning this is winning yeah if the pods
were on the g and h
files that's a different story for sure
right
but i rudely interrupted you you were
saying this is the first time the
holstein pressure has costed him i agree
i mean
uh costed that's not yeah costs
but anyway the point is that finally
alexi can
feel like he's in this match because it
must be so
frustrating when you are just kind of
cruising in many games
but you can't score the full point you
can't
now so quick on his feet i mean he's
able to generate these chances with two
seconds on the clock
it's a crazy but uh this is a big game
for alexi it shrinks the lead to three
and uh this next game is just as
important he's gonna have
the black pieces let's see if he can
shrink this lead further and half it
okay so it's seven at four and a half
and will we
get a repetition of the lines that we've
been seeing we have a maroon file
okay okay i always like the matches and
i'm a little biased in favor of that
different openings different types of
positions and can i ask your permission
for something robert
i made the mistake of bringing some
chocolate here and i have this little
chocolate
bar not a bar it's a square and i really
want to
get into it but can i mute myself for
one second and just
get rid of this while you talk you
certainly can
appreciate how considerate you were
there um i'm a little jealous because
you didn't
send me a chocolate bar but that's okay
this is amazing this line
is quite sharp in fact because black it
can steal this a2 pawn white has the
better center here
but the uh you know whoa queen bearing
b3 okay you defend the pawn so this is
typical
more pawns in the center an extra pawn
for white but black has the
queen side pawn majority so in the
immediate position white should be
favored
but in the long term in the prospects
the end game
black is the one who should be happy
because of the oh but here i think white
is just crashing through
like d5 immediately yeah and in the
grunfeld there's a couple of interesting
things to point out
one of them is that i always point this
out the upon majority for black
on the kick on the queen side right it's
two on one it favors black in a pawn end
game because then upon enemy it's gonna
be easier to create an outside passer
but but in a middle game a queenless
middle game
white's got that central pressure so as
long as he can keep the pieces on the
board
sticker rook on c7 keep the c file
dominance white is totally in control of
the game
yes indeed and because pieces the longer
the center they have more opportunities
from central squares that's why having
pawns in the center is good it restricts
the pieces and here knight b4 are you
really going after the a2 pawn can i
throw rook c7 in
to start hitting your bishop hitting
your b7 pawn threatening bishop c5
which hits your knight on before in your
pawn e7 that just looks
good for white to me totally and i'm
just a little distracted because i'm
discussing my chocolate choices with the
chat here but
yeah no rook c7 i mean the pawns start
just getting mowed down and vacuumed up
by the rook
bishop c5 now but wait a second yeah
knight takes a2 bishop takes d8 bishop
takes e7
and then we
almost then i lose it reminds me
i don't know if i have time to share the
story um the one time i got told off at
a chess game
just once by my former well coach and
amazing player grandmaster gregory
kaidanov he would host
a lot of u.s chess schools in kentucky
where he lives
and one camp i there was this inside
joke among the participants of the camp
we would share a line that we knew was
bad
only to say and i lose at the end of it
and for some reason that was funny to us
and i took that joke way too far and at
the la on the last day i kept sharing
these lines and saying and i was
and kaidana finally caught on to it he's
like he tells me in russian in the
middle of the campaign one more time
and we're gonna have a serious talk and
i'm gonna have a serious talk with your
mother after the class
and like okay okay okay okay and i got
beat red yeah
yeah anyway i was in a troll you thought
i was in the troll
all the trolls out there you're wrong
yeah you
you're the example made and you deserved
it clearly
what is happening in this game oh
because i think i lose
yeah the hell is down to about a minute
there are two pawns that can be captured
b7 and e7
but is this that kind of like typical
grunfeld compensation where
even though you're down something in
this case a pawn that
your pieces are working well yeah i mean
with the grip with the green field it's
one of those openings similarly to the
king's indian robert where it doesn't
matter how bad your position is
optically you're
always going to have certain chances
certain counter play
on one of the flanks and here we see
knight c3
he can try to go for bishop b5 that
knight on b7 is a little bit
stuck but it's got plenty of evacuation
squares now where does the bishop go
after
d3 it goes to d3 definitely
now bishop b5 getting prepared though
i'm telling you that knight on c3 in
combination with the rook on c8
it poses some difficulty to play yes
because
once the bishop gets to be fine with the
a pawn the a3 pawn feels like more of a
target
the united c3 stops this rook from going
to c1 there will be 92 check ideas
so not easy for you know to figure this
out he is up a pawn but he's down a
minute
and 15 seconds again oh and bishop d4
was an idea there even
oh nice bishop d for trying to remove
the guard yeah the rook on c
one watch out ninety two he stops yeah
watch out now the rook can see it is
undefeated rook c4 meets
with well rook c4 f3 even have a
revolution never okay
directly yeah i'm attacking this and i
like it
but bishop c5 maybe oh we're going to
count one by one here
yeah so yeah
alexi wisely is spending his time right
now this is a big moment
yeah to rook aid rook b8
rook c4 you guys wrote b8 to hit the
knight and then you can take e4 if he
wants it
yeah and uh knight c6 is what nihal's
aiming for wait a minute
he had knight c6 knight take c7 check by
the way
bishop h6 is there some kind of b4 at
some point i can't take him before
because rook check would turn the two
right
and by the way there is a cool idea by
by knee hall instead of rookie 7 to go
knight c6 and then take on e7
right but this is also very good i mean
he's going for the activity this is
looking very bad now
knight c6 he wants knight takes d5 but
even there we go rook d7
i like knight c6 here for oh but knight
63 is check
knight c6 knight d5 and then rook moves
the knight takes e3
four seconds he's gotta move okay and he
missed it i think
so 97 check and just trying to make a
draw oh he doesn't have a 93
that's the key yeah now 93 and then
rookie does alexi see it
yeah but this is an extra pawn for black
all of a sudden
but he's going to win it back oh but
rook a8 and all of a sudden you can take
off e3
so 97 the knight back to c6 you can't
take on a3 because rook d8 will be mate
the activity of white's pieces i think
garrett is clearly better for black
yeah no he's got an attempt here he
takes on h2
he wins the pawn he does and and the
time advantage again makes it very hard
to defend oh my goodness
rook a1 do you always a bishop g1 check
but i've moved the bishop back to d6
h5 okay it's the obligatory move in all
end games
it does feel that way often and a note
to everybody the bishop
does not match the corner h1 so if i can
straight off the f g
pawns we got this robert this is where i
get stressed out oh
gotta move you gotta move forward he's
going bishop g3 bishop g3
oh here's work up to check kenny seven
or king g7
rook f2 rook takes g2 thank you for a
pawn he literally was showing
zero zero zero but now black is simply
just winning on the position
yeah that pawn is too good bishop
anywhere
is your e1 maybe yeah and we can see
he blended upon no h3o h3 knight
sixty-five h2 rookie
that's a huge fun i'll give you the next
knight of strats
but he untraps the knight f3 look at me
all maneuvering you're defending
incredible
wow i mean it's still hard to defend
though he had that though in the bag
and now niho pushing his pawn up the
rook is activated he's threatening e6
so king seven and then he bring the king
up bishop b2
okay bishop c5 no work a7 check but i
thought the bishop was going to b2 it
hit the e5 pawn
because this way seven each game
be careful yeah don't take on e5 because
you dropped that fight the rook on a
dark square also worries me
okay never mind so king c6 g6 94 check
don't play
f6 f6 he's got to find f6 it's a truck
unbelievable wow just wow unbelievable
and for nihal he can just waste more
time i would decline it and
sir not you can just see the frustration
he he knows it's a draw
but he can't believe it i mean he was
he just had that in the back yeah and
he's wasting
more time from this three minute portion
we know that nihal is the favorite in
the bullet
and i mean nihal in his time
trouble he has really struggled at
points over the board but
the results are still in his favor the
man
is unbelievable he finds you know chance
after chance he complicates it
his time was dipping to point zero one
second and he found the chance to win a
pawn
uh that was incredible defense and now
uh
wait a second now robert careful is in
the wrong corner
your king is supposed to be in the other
corner this is actually going to be very
very hard to defend
well it's still a draw but yeah it's
going to take forever
it is you know we talk about this it's
not like unethical or anything to play
this he has every right to and he should
uh bleed the clock because this is also
easy to blunder him yeah and he gets the
king to the right corner
the important part of this end game is
that the king for white cannot create
opposition because you can check it off
when it's on a dark square
so oh no oh no
wow and neil laughed you see all that he
laughed a little bit he did and sarah
smiling as well he's just like what do i
have to do
oh my gosh in my lance
oh it's just crazy i'm gonna bring up
the old the
last game very quickly i need to analyze
just something to show people
where sorana blew his advantage
because way way way back when yep
i don't even know what move here was h4
knight g5 and if you play bishop e1
there's
a big difference that when the knight
comes to f3 you could still play h3
because you don't have access to this h4
square so if 91 i just push to h2 and i
get a queen it's not gonna be the
easiest win in the world
but that way your pawn could go wait
there's rook h4
i'm missing the rook h4 move what so i
bought it as myself so
wait a second oh wait i have an idea oh
my oh it doesn't work
i thought something crazy but no maybe
just like a
any other move like rook a red okay two
yeah just go somewhere you know
something like this way more difficult
than i expected i thought it was
gonna be easily winning but actually
there are tricks that allow one
even f6 to kick the knight yeah i see
the the bar still agrees that so is this
winning position oh bishop covers c7
that's that's very important but it's
easy to assume your opponent you know
with no time is just going to let the
pawn through but
uh not nehal oh my gosh i mean
that's the thing right even in post game
analysis i'm like oh it should be easy
wait wait a second
there's little tricks here and
just must be so frustrating to have
these kind of positions
and not only to to not win it but then
to to lose it to lose it
is just a knife i mean that's just a
dagger
but he's better again you've got one of
those end games and
i feel like once again white is better
but we've seen this
been the narrative of the match no
better better better time pressure for
me hall but he finds
every single chance yeah and rook
g1 just played to defend the bishop i
guess and maybe try to go for a g5 this
feels like
one of these positions where it's not
clear where the punches are going to be
thrown but you just need to do something
as you were down
four points here wow
14 minutes left i mean alexi needs to
start
getting on streaks he can't just win one
game and then
have nihal strike back unless he needs
to win two in a row
otherwise he's two and he needs to have
the lead within two points i think
yes nihal is without a doubt the favor
of the bullet but
alexi has been fast he's been on form
and
anything can happen in the bullet we
know that but he needs to set himself up
for that if it's a four or five point
lead uh someone like neha i mean he's
just not gonna let that slip
i think no he will not and both players
have had
uh this kind of setup from both colors
and
it is an end game where the rook on b5
is very nice putting pressure on b2
the a4 pawn could be considered over
extended
but not so easy to get to and what's
happening here
this is interesting now rook takes c5 he
wants to get his knight around maybe but
now he goes comes back to b5 he ties
himself to that b coupon
okay there was some kind of like knight
d5 net for check stuff but
there is now 95 now to stop knight c3
maybe it should be considered
again the time in saranac's favor is up
and i get up a minute but it's like
doesn't matter maybe you should try
going down a minute and see if that
helps right exactly
just sit there until he's got 30 seconds
he's been up a minute plenty of times
and it's not working out for him
and nihil just very sharp in these
critical moments so let's see
knight d5 you mentioned in the way stop
knight c3 how big of a deal is knight c3
you played knight c3 i played rook a5
you attacked my pawn yeah and b6
six okay that's a pretty committal move
but i suppose he's
well rook d2 now the thing that that
one has to be concerned about if you
need all those pawns on the queen side
of it they're just
weak they're tender but he's trying to
use active defense here ward off the
immediate pressure
yeah if you're a c5 my king can actually
even consider kind of the c
or mine does exactly that all right
so you can't play b5 the c5 is hanging
this is very unpleasant king e5
maybe
can you make that sound effect again no
i don't
it's like this person does not exist you
know can you be five
uh excuse me uh rook
don't get mated though i'm not gonna e5
king e5 king e5 yeah um that's probably
a good move
knight c3 though yeah at that point you
can trade knights
wait is there a mate that's a rook c4 or
k5
yeah that would be a self mate good but
if i go rook d one
are you playing rookie five in kingston
66.
he might be five nice check here king c6
rook d5
oh free knight just kidding b5 check
thank you for
and he does that center maybe 96 here i
don't know no that's crazy
okay so knight back to c3 and so
b5 no knight b5 knight b6 oh
very clever i was like beef has to work
unbelievable again he's knight b6 knight
c4 is an idea the question is does he
keep the knights he's got to decide fast
no but rook a8 i mean it's even worse
probably not in rook a7 just to keep the
seventh rank defended make sure g7 h7
feel nice and
uh safe over there and well
takes kc e4 he wants to ki 3 f4 but
this could be a risky end game yep
and uh well okay the pawn end game again
we talked about the smaller pawn
majority g5
no g5 looks very good that's crunching
through
and then the kingdom's d5 this is
winning for black it must be
it is and g5 ends the game
he's still and he's calculating
[Music]
f3 and you get as they call them
trousers and you would go
c4 and then b4 and c3
okay well let's see how you want to go
b4 are you going to go f3
yes yeah you're right you start pushing
the pawns and then you go c4 the one
thing you've got to be careful about
yeah f3c4
okay this also works this is the
conventional method
and wait a second yeah he's gonna do it
gotta be careful see foreign
c3 and a3 and it was super important
that c3 attacks
something because uh we'll we'll we'll
show this in another win for anyhow
great technique we'll bring up this game
just to show you a very
important sequence here that after b4
check king to d3 b
takes a3 would be incorrect because when
you get to this position
now when you play c4 c3 you're not
actually attacking the pawn on b2
so in the event of f3 king e3 c4 i take
and c3 doesn't threaten c takes b2 and
so i can just play king e3 and i'm
in the box right my king is just in time
to uh
survive this so that would be a really
bad decision
easy to to do something like that but
you know taking his time
and this is i mean incredible display
here
right typical pawn sacrifice that's one
of the
initial end games you learn is you give
a pawn in the center and then spring
free
uh another so this was a really nice
finish by nihal in another
game by alexia where you're just like is
there any way to beat this guy
yeah try my best what kind of position
do i need to get
how much of a time pressure do i need to
put this guy in does it matter he's
going to find chances now we have
a very unbalanced position alexi doing
when he has to and
we remind the viewers that alexi a
trooper for playing this
during a tournament uh he's playing the
russian higher league
which is far from something to sneeze at
uh and uh he's been tremendous here so
this is certainly not a match that
i would call over he's going to try his
best but
these last 10 minutes are pivotal if he
wants any chance at all of fighting back
yeah and for alexi maybe he used up
a lot of his good fortune against
jeffrey because in those first three
games
alexey himself said in the post-match
interview he's like i was losing
i was lost and somehow he scored two and
a half to three in those games
against jeffrey and i i don't think this
is
exactly the same scenario but there have
been times where nihal has just been in
trouble and yet he is the one
who has just been claiming all of the
points i mean nine and a half four and a
half against a player of alexis caliber
after beating hike marty rosian by an
incredible score
neil sarin is just worthy right that guy
is going to be in the speed chest
championship he keeps this
up and he is not going to be an easy out
no matter which super
massive face and uh he's got a very
bright future in tournament chess as
well he's
incredibly what's always struck me about
him is how versatile he is he can play
so many different types of positions
he's only 16 years old
he's over 2600 so uh he is a force to be
reckoned with as of course is alexi
sardar
uh and and it's really uh such a treat
to watch these players
form and grow before our very eyes
for sure and well i'm looking at this
game
donya the bivinic variation always
immensely complicated what's going on
with this b4 c3 you typically don't want
to allow
that protected pawn on c3 you'd like to
play a3 and start
chipping away but that doesn't seem like
it's going to happen and i like
sauron's position here
well i do as well then one thing that
concerns me is of course the screen on
d5 it's under the
x-ray of the bishop there's nothing that
i can do with it here
that's a brave move isn't it rookie one
queen e5 is his idea or queen b6
yeah and you can't castle king's side
because this bishop that is a problem
but you could go knight t6 in some of
these positions and then you have like
crazy ideas of stacking on e6 right you
can just like
bring all the forces hey i agree with
you robert this is this is not looking
good for white
and at the very least for alexia draw is
heading into losing territory because
you need to start winning we keep
talking about this
and you have chances here that's for
sure what's the material account white
has six pawns
black hat wait it's even material
wait it is why no it's not six what's
the sixth one
i'm looking at this as if they're
slipping four paw whites up three points
no
that's crazy i was exactly the same well
well this h2 pawn
doesn't really feel relevant yet but in
end games in particular you just start
running that pawn up the board and
black's pawns look far more menacing on
b4 and cd yeah but you can play a3
perhaps undermine them
that's true that's a useful idea so c5
wait what
whoa whoa excuse me isn't there not a
rook on a8 that is not happy to see the
bishop one g2
oh it's the bishop on g2 is happy to see
the row
okay so we have this f6 is hanging oh
bishop e5
first okay but now what i was worried
about is um
queen e4 bishop c6 so queen e4
protecting the bishop and also lying
bishop c6 with a pin
well i guess black has some okay drops
his bishop back he takes a more measured
approach maybe bishop e2 he wants to
play
just castle but bishop should be seven
yeah
look at that diagonal have fun castling
danya that's right right exactly
in fact cast yourself out queen c6 f3
there's knight g4 h2 this is under
attack here
but okay but knight g4 if we extend that
line
knight g4 i'm going to go bishop g5
and i'm going to threaten mate of my own
oh i'm gonna play it oh if i have f60
you're just a mean i'll throw in bishop
d4 check i have to stop you from making
it yes i'm gonna take it
what are you doing here
[Music]
yeah you you don't believe in this
position yeah no i don't
oh man so he's always found something
though wait
you're coming back to c7 i don't know
about that though he's threatening
bishop g3 i mean that's clearly the idea
13 seconds 10 seconds about to be had by
nihal here we go with this again how can
you defend this
if he defends this position with seven
seconds crazy
queen i mean i guess he can play queen
f2 oh my
goodness oh now he's threatening me
again it's me oh
my goodness and brook seat is obviously
not oh
i once said again knight d5 maybe alex
you should have played
because now knight d5 you could take and
open up that e file
true and there's a bishop c5 checked
that you have to worry about because the
knight on d5 means that the bish 25 is
not defended once something captures c5
i'm telling you this is unbelievable
bishop g5 is another idea on f4
although that does open up the long
diagonal
yeah bishop c5 oh my
oh rook d6 and the wheels come off
so oh she takes everything keeping the
pin alive removing the defenders
and three pawn
oh my god so precise training the queen
just trade them this is still in here
phenomenal for him
and he resigns unbelievable turnaround i
mean
the guy is a defensive maestro yeah he
is
carter kuryakin has that nickname
minister of defense but
he's the whole has something to say
about that in this match
he's reminding me of grishoug honestly
playing better with no timeouts exactly
he's just waiting for his time to take
down says all right now time to turn it
on
and alexi played e4 in this game by the
way so now we have a martial attack
where black is down to pawn but there's
plenty of compensation especially if
you're g3 look at the
light squares around white's king that's
something that you'd like to take
advantage of
but this is still theoretical territory
and the lead is ballooned to six points
and that is a huge huge lead given the
kind of form that nihal is in uh
what does serrano do how much time is
left in the match two minutes this might
be the last game of the three minute
segment
we've been saying it all along i mean 93
by the way
93. is that not i mean rook takes e394
wins the exchange back but
remember black sacked the pawn and he
can win it back oh this is just
collapsing here yeah we're no good no
good 94 just rook takes e4 as you're
suggesting and then you you
can sound better yeah you have two
bishops and yeah i mean your opponent
also has two bishops but your bishops
are better developed
uh your king is safe and you you can't
play f5 now but i'm looking at king h8
f5 f4 as an option you can repeat also
rookie it also looks good you're right
yeah this is nasty and you feel for
alexi you know it's something
we talk about this you know you take
blow after blow
and at some point you just reach the end
of your rope what do i have to do you
know i'm getting these positions i can't
convert them
and uh you know the tilt sort of happens
gradually and
uh you know at this we can celebrate the
amazing performance by siren while also
sympathizing with alexi who has put his
heart on the line every one of these
matches
yeah he has and he's not going to give
up even though he's down by six points
and
he also happens to be the better player
but he just
he must be so frustrated and like what
can he do what more can he do he needs
to put away the games where he has an
advantage
that obviously has been in his control
throughout the entire match
but most people they get down to their
waning seconds they just lose the game
with any move that's played nihal not
one of those guys just
yeah it's incredible and and not only is
he able to find quality moves he's
what impresses me is that he's not
deterred by sudden moves and time versus
normally with two seconds
you don't have time to react to
something crazy but he it seems like he
spends those last two seconds and then
generates a move it's an incredible
sight to behold
but we know that in the bullet there is
more than seven or eight games played so
mathematically anything is possible and
neither of these players is giving up or
relaxing
yeah actually something you were just
saying is
very striking it's almost as if
nihal is anticipating the unexpected and
that is
so hard to train yourself to do like
when you have
three seconds in your clock and there's
a full board so many different options
but to be able to expect maybe a move on
the other side of the board or
one just that doesn't really do much of
anything so you also have to make a
patient move so hard
to drain that kind of focus and board
vision
and talents that that takes is
incredible and he possesses
all of that and more and let's see this
end game is looking
good for black because after queenie e4
fe4
maybe it should be a draw but white
can't punch through
his you know palm majority at all and
now
we just took on a4 because the bishop
was hanging play a3 and
black as well and now a pass upon and
now a bishop end game is also going to
be winning for black
and this might be another win and that
would be a seven point game
coming into the one minute segment
sarnath's got to try to save this
but so draw probably
maybe oh yeah he does oh he simply works
but nihal says okay
no reason to go crazy it's a six point
game
and uh a miracle only a miracle is going
to save sir enough from the clutches of
nihal siren
what more is there to say then nihal
sarin is
an absolute monster the guy is not to be
deterred
i from the very beginning of the match
was thinking hey he's getting some time
trouble
sarnath thrives in those situations but
it has been
all nihalsan the grandmaster teenager
from india
he's such a superstar right now and he
has big sponsorship deals and he's about
to
win this junior speeches championship
and make his way
to the speed chest championship where as
i said dania i really think he could
pull off a first run upset there
indeed i believe he can he is incredibly
talented he is delivering on his
reputation
uh but he has 30 minutes of one plus one
left and so does sarna
to make a miracle happen we'll see
whether that in fact occurs
but first the players are going to take
a break and so are we we'll be right
back everybody
stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we returned ready for the bullet
portion of this match
dania it looks like it's nihal saron's
match to win but there is a lot of prize
money at stake
and the prizes are given by win
percentage so it's not just the winner
and loser get x amount of dollars no no
no no every single game counts and as
you see here
2500 the winner and the invitation to
the speeches championship
plus the rest is split by one percentage
another 2 500
so daniel quite a big payday indeed a
lot at stake
and a lot of pride at stake and
definitely the speed chess championship
a very coveted ticket at stake as well
uh so not only are you know they still
playing for the match and
it's never over till it's over but as
you mentioned
every single game counts in terms of the
prize money
so we have 30 minutes of bullet here six
point lead for me hall that's huge
obviously particularly considering how
much of a beastie is in bullet
we can see already uh alexi has taken
his seat he's prepared him what did you
tell yourself if you're if you're
relaxing in this situation
um nothing you hadn't you had a great
run
uh second place is still a phenomenal
performance so kudos to you
now you have to just move honestly i
don't know how to beat nihal sarn in
bullet chest
if i did i would be somewhere much
closer to his rating but
you just have to move and you have to
win immediately so you don't if you
draw a game and it takes you four
minutes it's equivalent to a loss at
this point because you're down so much
in the scoreboard
so you just have to move as quickly as
possible and hope that it works out for
you
no sure i don't know how to beat him as
well and we've seen him
put on a display in the bullet and win
the match at the bullet segment alone
uh and and i agree i mean following your
intuition is
absolutely key just forcing it out of
yourself essentially
and and not taking that 30 seconds you
know the critical moment
i just you know this is a lesson that if
you are
not you would have hoped you've learned
it earlier in the match because now it's
bullet that is
uh it is nihal's forte and
we're off here 11 to 5 and we are
getting
a qgd a ragosan heading our way
indeed uh that's we've seen a lot of
openings here on display which i really
like different structures
uh different approaches and uh this is a
very solid line for white
and one of black's ideas of course black
has the two bishops normally black goes
a6
bishop d6 okay he takes on c3 that's a
more modern approach to this line
uh but i've always felt like white is
slightly better in the structure he's
got that b
file pressure he's got that wedge in the
center right you have
uh the extra pawn right in the center
here very safe and sound
there are no useful discoveries you can
move your knight to e5 but that would
have just allowed the queen to retreat
so e5 played
the queen mosaic and that's what's so
nice by having the c3 e3 pawns the
center is reinforced so down here
knight a5 trying to make use of the
light squares on the queen side
is black in time to seize control of
them
well he's got e4 that's pretty
interesting uh
and i suppose that's what the battle is
going to revolve around
what is going to happen in the center
knight b3 is possible he plays it
and then c4 d5 white is definitely
better i think
uh even if from a practical perspective
but i do really like what cern is doing
he keeps challenging nihal's control
over the center
yeah miss rook d2 rook d1 and if you
take on d4 take out the rook
use that open file to advantage c4 c4
driving it in
yeah with pc on the board it's better to
have more pawns towards the center
that's why the v3 c4 configuration is
nice
in the pure end game having the outside
pass pawn could be useful but it takes
with the bish1c4 no outside passport for
you
dino this is just better pieces pretty
much every single one for white
yeah beautiful outpost square squid e5
now a4 is
one thing you have to watch out for
which nihal takes care of with this move
rook a6
uh this is uh well the default queen g5
defends the a5 pawn the rook does
leave the defile and nihal very solid
going for the queen trait he doesn't
even really mind the long draws
not to suggest this is a draw lexi is
the one who has to uh
prove prove the defense here in fact how
does black key
yeah i don't know if i see how it might
survive this honestly
there was another tough position here i
mean i'll take on a5 right away
crunches that pawn yeah and you still
have
full complete control over the d file
you can't even get a rook d of rook d7
so just painful honestly indeed and
now he's going to add an attack to the
mix rook d8 is a threat
queen d8 just that's a good move
practicable
very practical he's up upon he can play
this for a year and
he's probably winning at the end of it
yes he's the ideal set of circumstances
e4 and a light square there it goes
bishop d5 thank you for the pawn
and was the king gonna go to h4 and self
mate rook d5 check is coming oh gotta
try it
here's definitely g5
h5 now i would just take well no it
takes bishop h3
h5 is actually a very good move i was
thinking f3 because you don't have rook
c2
but there might be like rook a7 you know
trying to get around that one
rook t4 is nice because now if you take
on g4 you walk into a pin now the b-pawn
goes
and this has been a story of the defile
that won him the game he collected the
puns and
it's symbolic that his rook remains on
the deep file all throughout
essentially yeah kg3 now should be good
he was b5
just put he's gonna keep pushing the
pawn rook b4 is also possible
if need be b7 oh rook d8
next yep it's over and another win for
knee hall and such a smooth game
particularly for bullet he's up 20
seconds he's winning the game and
there's a resignation 32-83 so he had
his rating has actually decreased since
we started the junior speeches
championship
her live with that right i think he'll
be okay 32 83
let's get serious here what a slacker
i know but yeah he'll be okay
with losing 20 bullet points as long as
he makes his way to the sec
absolutely that's what's important here
and we have a queen's indian
i mean yeah this is this is just rough
this is rough
but i like white's position in these
types of structures because he's got
that pressure on the devon
but it's hard to follow through on that
black can assign all of his resources
the task of defending the pawn
and if black pushes white away rook d70
doubles things could turn around slowly
but surely
yeah the only good news about having
some a6 is it could be a night a
fortnight b6 you to be careful for
just think about anytime you move upon
what the consequence is and knight of
three check
oh yeah he just trades in that f6
he's following the strategy of playing
very solid uh
long games and not giving anything up
you know easily
he's playing so much more quickly and
you may say duds bullet
but he's playing much more quickly in
the bullet and seems more
confident so this is his time control he
did say as much
after last match that he loves playing
bullet just a lot of fun yeah he's
terrible at five-minute chess and he's
so badly there so weak obviously
it just seems like he really finds his
form in
at the end of the match which is scary
when he was already up six points
heading into the quickest time control
right it's it's crazy it is absolutely
crazy and 94 i guess
g4 queen f4 knight h5 oh you've queen a4
oh that's close though it's so close and
he's thinking maybe c4
first but then the queen is the d4
square oh
no stop it yeah
why do you have to be so mean yeah i'm
sorry man but actually g4 queen of four
d4 if you eat then knight h5 does trap
the queen but i really like this move
because 95 oh that's
that's something that's because i guess
you got to move your rook out of the
picture
wait and he gets back back
huh interesting choice to go back to f6
rook h8 now a threat so yeah
does he see a rookie shape then work h1
okay
yeah you can take take quincy check but
how far are you really getting there
right not very far i think you just have
to fight your time maybe a5
maybe d4 a fight with d4 there's also g4
possibilities
just straight along the d file black's
very solid here and he's got a bad the
passer
he does and you can play g4 queen e4
things like that and i mean earlier we
would have
probably said well neil is eight seconds
but we've grown so used to
excellence from him with no time on the
clock that it doesn't even seem to be a
deterrent now
i wasn't even noticing it honestly right
exactly
so d3 three queen takes d5 in rook t3
there was no discovery
he's going to be down upon here i think
but it's not easy to get to that pawn if
you go kiki 2 you go you run into 94
knight g4 king e2
yeah something oh now if you take
there's a pork at the end of it
very important so do you start with 92
or something then there's knight g4
check and knight back that's right
oh and black wins oh my god
oh you black was winning there was a
king
what am i saying like this i mean
this is an extra pawn for white so at
least alexa can play this out
ah he's very tied down though he is
this good yeah knight c3 i guess net h1
wow that's a hilarious move these this
is gonna be a race it's anybody's game
honestly i mean these races it doesn't
matter who's up upon it's about the
quality of the past one
right and one pawn does move faster than
two because you're right two together
yeah but wait here two yeah that's
that's not a good transformation and
white should be winning king d2 that way
you can try play you can't play rook v6
it was rookie
h2 check but now the pawns are going b5
a4
etcetera and the king is close enough to
the f-bomb right
f3 this is a mistake wait a minute he
might be losing here if he is not
careful
you have to give a bunch of checks yeah
but the king just stops the
the rook from coming to the eighth ring
so the black king will go back and forth
king e3 not possible f2 that's a good
move though but he goes rook before
something like that so roxy won rook f1
and then after rookie for those kings oh
you guessed work at five king c3 qc3
yeah but now the king approaches and
this is one of those theoretical end
games
yeah i should be winning king rotation
yeah b6 at some point simply now
king c5 king b5 and keep marching up
here this has been known since the 17th
century
quite literally you build a bridge and
here it comes king a7 king b6 king c6
this never gets old there's a certain
elegance to this uh lucina
plan that always you know
entices me every time i see it i'm going
to pull up that last game for half a
second because i want to show something
you know what i would do
expecting my opponent i'm losing right i
know i'm lost i've played rook c7 hoping
for the pre-movement rook before
right that way i can take your
absolutely silly but
you know these are just little bullet
tricks that should not work out
i just think that you have to try
something i gotta try what you gotta try
yep and uh that was a great game my sir
and i mean he's staying calm i don't
think
he's gotten massively tilted or anything
of that sword i mean of course he got
upset i think there are a couple of
games where
he was under the influence of those
games he failed to win
uh but by and large he's remained
level-headed it's just been nehal's
incredible form that has carried the
match yeah
plus six 20 minutes to go technically
there's an
outside shot that you can win six in a
row and tie it but
if we're being realistic nihal just the
monster of all monsters here and
what's going on in this game black
people should have six as possible
well black is up so much time yo chest
12 seconds
i don't think nihal has been down on
time ever in this match actually
first try very good integration
i mean got to work on that so let's see
now white is down 20 seconds and there's
a lot of trouble here
black has the bishop queen h7
king but where do you go from here
because queen g okay but now night of
night back tonight
nine of five fighter five oh no you
didn't
yes i did nothing that was so cool that
was winning
wasn't it this also looks really good
though yeah it does d5
crunch and d6 oh my gosh g6 not only
takes away the score of thrones d7
forking your rooks yup 97 oh yeah yeah
then d6 is you mentioned
98 probably you have to try but then d6
again
that's exactly what you said oh my
goodness hm8
can't stop both d67 or d6
you've got to try to trap the queen
somehow and go bishop takes that three
queen eight oh wow that's interesting
you could actually take on e7 and take
on f3 i think that's a nemo kind of
thing to do
you can play queen of shape bishop h7
queen g8 mate oh that's also a ufo thing
to do
that's a robert hess thing to do ouch
ouch ouch i rub my
my itchy nose and just there's nothing
more you can say about this just
it's a demolition absolute demolition
and
we have a question that i'm gonna air
out and put you on the spot robert
from our again our amazing producer
uh and our entire production team bick
if you're down
this much in a match how you know sort
of quote-unquote dirty do you get do you
left someone do you go
for the bishop h6 trick uh is that
totally frowned upon or
is there some sense to just doing that
when you're this losing in a match
yeah i mean who as long as you're trying
to get back on the scoreboard like who
cares how you do it most times doesn't
cost you the game so it
um you know it won't work and you look
silly
but no i'm serious that's right if you
do something that's just not
if you play if you play bishop takes c4
hoping for some pre-move
and they don't pre-move and they just
take your bishop then you look like the
fool but if you play bishop c4 and they
make some other move then you look
really smart so that's really
the two ends of that and personally when
i
i don't really like bullet regardless
but if i'm playing and somebody does
that it
really ticks me off but then i'm just
like i mean what they didn't do anything
wrong
they just did something silly and i fell
for it
i used to take it very personally and
get very mad
uh but but you know you realize that
it's the people don't always have this
agenda of
you know deeply disrespecting people
just going for the win
and uh it's it's not very nice but at
the end of the day you know you just
don't pre-move you know
it's you're getting a chance to win the
game very fast
it's on you that you've decided to
pre-move at the end of the day your
opponent doesn't owe it to you to be
nice on the chessboard no
he doesn't so what's going on
with sarina's connection it feels like
yeah he
frequently had one or two bars in this
game and
he might just lose on time because yeah
95 95 c4 and then i comes into d3
and uh even without the time disparity
yeah
58 seconds to two seconds look at this
yeah the internet is not
serna's friend here and neither is the
position
no and let's see queen
h5 through knight f3 so the king is
going back and forth a little bit
and he just repeats rook d6 by the way
is an interesting idea he's just going
to drop on time isn't he rook d6
and 94 and he loses on time
that's brutal and
indeed the connection worsening uh
at the worst possible time during the
bullet he's got that one bar and that's
not helping him
helping things for alexi yep
and was it now seven eight points
wow 14 to six after 20 games played
yeah and unfortunately for lexi it's
just getting worse with his
connection seemingly yeah we remind
people just joining that alexi is not
playing from home he's playing from
a hotel room uh he's playing an over the
board tournament right now so
huge kudos to alexi for nonetheless
finding the time
to play the match uh that's you know it
could have easily said you know we
demanded a reschedule but uh really a
classy classy guy and very modest we've
seen him in the interviews
uh both of them really so absolutely and
for neal he adjusted his schedule to
play earlier than expected
and it's certainly panning out for him
in this matchup and for alexi we
he's got a few games bullet left and
then he'll be playing the russian higher
league where
of course we wish him uh the best of
luck in that event it's gonna be
such a tough event with all the not just
top russian players but players
flying for their yeah you know
um actually no it is just russia right
the russian higher league i think yeah i
was thinking
yeah because sometimes in the leagues uh
you can have foreign players
wouldn't take say five then by the way
with you mr pawn
oops oh there's bishop before at the end
of that oh
that's cool but this looks still very
good he's driving in the pond that's
like a london dream queen to v2 look at
the piece
shifting around v6 is a good move under
mining the one
and now we don't have a symmetrical pawn
structure because a versus b
but i think that if you win the b you
lose the a and vice versa so it's going
to be tough to
prove an advantage here it is and uh for
new hall it's all about
you know playing solid chess bleeding
out the clock
at this point there are 15 minutes below
15 minutes left in the match
this is we remind you they are also
playing for oh
wait bishop f591 oh but then bishop
before maybe
you're okay yeah you sneaky sneaky guy
he just takes on a5 instead um and there
is prize money tied up in the actual
results so every game matters
true knight e5 maybe i mean the position
is just better for what because the pawn
structure black has some current
activity
but you need to keep d5 f5 all defending
and now
jump around knight c5 roxy one to follow
as well
i don't c2 has to be watched over queen
a7 looks good
oh going after f7 they're going queen to
d7 perhaps 57's next
27 is coming oh he goes to a4 springs it
up here
it's hard to even make okay there here
comes 27. can't stop it
bishop c7 is a really nice move that's
pain that's just
it is flat out pain and bishop d6 i mean
it's it's literally just target practice
here it's mowing down the pawns
knight d7 is also good oh it just takes
94 97 anything
knight f6 another possible six
this is no fun i mean he makes it look
easy i that expression is overused and
it's a huge cliche
but he makes it look easy he does he
just checked me with the guy
queen g7 queen g4 is made yup
that's that's just incredible
what is happening like it's 15 to 6
and there's still just under 13 minutes
left yeah i mean it's
one feels for alexi when you're taking
this sort of a beating you know you just
look at the match clock
all right all right when will this end
uh and
it's i mean it's incredible really what
whitney hall's doing
just
i wish i had the words to describe
what's happening yeah
lexi against sam sevien and that was
that game
assumed that match came down to the
final game where sevien actually had a
winning position
but alexi fended him off and won that
game and one by two i think it's jeffrey
alexey was dominant on the scoreboard in
both the five and the three minute
time segment and then jeffrey almost you
know he's in the version making a real
comeback in the bullet but he
didn't have enough time he ended up
losing by uh three games so i'm not
mistaken
so alexia has proven himself to be a
formidable opponent
but somehow nihal is just next level
right now yeah he is every time to troll
every position
i impossible to bring down in bad
positions ruthless in good positions
tricky in equal positions it just i mean
it's been a force just to be reckoned
with here
and uh you know nobody likes to see a
beating
and i think it's important to again as i
said keep two things in mind here on the
one hand to
truly uh celebrate and and sort of uh
appreciate the incredible strength of
nihal and at the same time to
uh congratulate alexi on an amazing uh
on his amazing play throughout the
tournament and to sympathize with him
you know it's never easy to to be on the
receiving end of this kind of beating
no certainly not he can score a couple
of wins down the stretch to make himself
feel a little bit better not too much
but ninety
nine six ninety seven five so there's
more tactics
over there yeah just trying to sit on
the position but somehow nihilism
yeah king g7 he's going to twist his
pieces around
he's going to perform some gymnastics
and he's going to be better in like five
hours
yeah he's uh playing devilish defense
which i guess is only fitting because
apparently
we had a quote from nihal before the
match and we interviewed him well we did
but somebody did and
he said his friends call him the devil
sometimes and i think we see why
and he's slaughtered is what it is his
position isn't very good though right
now
no but that hasn't stopped him that's
true it certainly has not
um he's got his rook on e6 is a good
defender he's
keeping his 98 to stop any kind of
knight f6
but he's very much tied down here you
can't play c6 that drops b6 oh and a
nice idea well actually h4 king h3 just
inching in but you got to be careful
when you're in 97.97
yeah 97 and it finds it and whether
where there is a knight there is trouble
but
this is queen e7 knight she's seven six
e6
drives the pawn in queen g5 though queen
e fight f5
oh my goodness that's all very close
yeah you get you thankfully get the
queen because otherwise this
little fork here would have been alexa
gets this one faster
yep the queen takes up five queen e3
so queen me queen b2 to the last drop of
blood
every game that is
why do you bring this king up to c2
okay nice try that knight if i was smart
if there was one less attacker on e7
that would have been more effective
yeah and alexi just says all right i'm
getting a king and i'm getting checkmate
and um yeah
yeah for alexi he just
will try to get a couple more his bullet
rating is
30 39 even notice that because he's
looking but 32 in front of
nihal's rating but alexa clearly
no no beginner when it comes to their
[ __ ]
is incredible again that really only
only hikaro can can compete with uh
you mean i would say both of them are so
incredibly strong uh
and uh yeah this is this has been a
treat
to watch these players 95 nihal jumping
on ahead here
the opening yeah the queens are coming
off so it looks like
shouldn't be too big of an advantage for
either side but
there's plenty of life left if the
queens are not traded and black can even
play queen eight if you're not careful
so that's why the queens came off
right knight t3 here creating that pin
against the bishop
this might fizzle out if alexi is able
to ward off the immediate initiative
and before just bishop
moves back to d6 okay not that big a
deal [ __ ] should be five rookies seven
this should be five could be nasty
because rookie seven will take the
bishop
okay definitely better with the two
bishops yeah yeah for sure these bishops
are great
so and bishop
moving well then i might find the bishop
that rook and you want you got to be
careful about
rookie eight how do you wait five three
f three oh and five mississippi five oh
oh you defend the rook
oh so that's gonna drop to g3 to keep
the rook
defended here it could have gone d2 as
well but now c5 is really hanging
and i don't know if sorry not has a move
here
well you get the e file that's what's
important here oh and he also attacks
the knight then that's a
that's a devastating pin rook d8 rook
takes c5
thank you yep and that's in exchange and
rook takes
takes boom yeah back ranker
there's the background mate which is
music capture
it's over another
smooth display by knee hall who's not
taking the foot off the gas pedal
yeah yeah in these situations you know
it's not easy to say anything you know
it's it's match has been decided they're
playing for some prize money
rook takes c4 by the way wins the game
on the spot and he finds it
uh but i'm just sad this is coming too
now this has been
and i'm sure we'll talk about it in the
end robert but
what an event this has been and what a
match this has been
yeah it's a little strange it feels like
we were so spoiled earlier in the
bracket
and there were many close matchups
coming down to the absolute wire for
example nihal against anton smirnov
was super close uh saranac versus sevien
was really as close as he gets and
then in the 70s in the finals somehow
instead of the matches getting more
competitive they've almost become
less competitive yeah that just happens
sometimes you know because
the players are in different frames of
mind uh you never know what's going to
happen and
the great thing about the gscc is it's
not like one of those things where you
have a round of 32 and there's clear
favorites
i think one of the the you know the
magic of this event
um apart from the players themselves
where the strengths of the players
always being close even in the opening
matches
anything can happen in any match so we
were on the edge of our seats
essentially every single match yes
that's the case and
i mean all credit should go to nihal
because in the
first matches andrew tank he looked very
mighty then against anton smirnov we're
like
wait this guy is actually very beatable
and he was losing in the five-minute
portion of smirnoff he was even losing
after the end of the three minute if i'm
not mistaken to smear it off and then
the bullet is where he
decided to you know that was the time to
shine and
after that so i guess not even just have
it with the exception
of that match it hasn't looked close in
his other badges so nihal
something about smirnoff style was tough
for nihal otherwise he has just been an
absolute just demon
and that's why his friends call him that
and and it's yeah one gets the sense the
confidence level and just the ability to
play
all of these types of positions with
time pressure it's it's the
set of skills being as well-rounded as
as it is i mean he's
i think definitely going to be above
2700
uh he's you know you can just sense the
talent and the
the maturity level and the versatility
um and
uh he is the very well deserved going to
be the very well-deserved winner of the
jscc a tournament that is going to be
fascinating for years and years to come
robert
and with the addition of the four
qualifiers from the speeches
championship grand prix and vladimir
putin say
you know getting second place in the
super swiss but because the car nakamura
is already qualified
we have some players who um in that
ballpark of neil siren right there's
very strong players who may not be
2750 plus fide so it i'm very curious
who nihal's first round matchup will be
because some players
are much more difficult than others
especially stylistically
but i do think that nihal i've said this
throughout the match today
he has a chance no matter who he faces
anybody i do believe he does
not want to face hikaru nakamura i don't
know why
he's pretty easy to pretty easy opponent
but no i mean he's got a chance against
anybody particularly if he displays the
same kind of confidence
uh and and ability to survive and thrive
in time pressure
but uh that's going to be an incredible
event in its own right
this format there's something about this
format whether it was the i am not a gm
whether it was the jscc the scc
it brings out not only the best in
players but it just makes it so
competitive it makes it
so fun to watch you get all of the time
control showcased
and you get a little bit of everything
which is awesome
indeed indeed and three minutes left
of the jscc we know that nihal sarn is
the champion
uh now this is just a formality at this
point
and will he be able to take this game is
king is far more active there's rookie
two check
that you have to keep an eye on so
right here it comes that king needs to
be on c3 not on
g3 rook f3 forces the game to the second
rank maybe you chase the knight away now
i don't know
okay knight d7 hitting v6 but the rook
yeah comes back in defense
despite the symmetrical pawn structure
it's a very unbalanced position the fact
that black's king is so far it really
hurts him in relation
to the pawns but he chases the night
away from the position of the knights of
the dancing
it's funny don you see it hurts him with
relation to the pawns totally agree but
it helps him
if you keep the rooks on the board and
create an attack like king f2 king e290
yeah
it can walk in all of a sudden so i have
to be a bit careful here
here comes the king and white's king
inches inches further into its little
cave there on a3 but
that's going to be smoked out with a
knight so he comes back rookie 6 again
the dance
knight e3 and that you called it king e2
that's going to happen
all of a sudden the attack is going to
be made it could be a quick mating net
bikini two is rookie's two checks
and so alexi finding ways king e2 now
sliding the king in rook h6 i would play
rook d1 coming oh here we go here's rook
d1 that's exactly what you called
where exactly is the knight
this is amazing oh my gosh united 192
mate
knight f192's mate oh my god oh this is
incredible
how oh my
that ness was that is the
tuple exclamation mark on top i'm
pulling up that board
that is what is that that was sick
king c2 thinking that you're going after
the b-pawn but it's all about mating
this king
the king has no safe squares after
knight b6 93
that's a pawn need a knight end game oh
my
god you found that instantly well the
king
would only have one escape square after
you pushed the pawns incredible geometry
incredible
and 92 made what a final position
i mean that's the absolutely this is
just illegal i mean this is just
ridiculous
at this point and oh wait what's
happening here the bishop one before he
just lost the bishop maybe he's not even
stopping he's just
stepping on that gas pedal 97 i guess is
fine for luck though
right because if knight takes e7 you can
always take on c3 but now queen before
but that was just something out of a
study yeah that was that was wonderful
castle queen stuff i think for white now
yeah
that that was just unbelievable
94 oh gosh here it comes
now what's particularly impressive is
how he hasn't let up and it's not out of
uh
i'm not saying this to imply that he
should have
he's he's just displaying the same
exquisite level of play
uh even in the bullet even though
obviously the match
has been decided for quite a while now
what a beast like they're i'll be honest
there were moments where i was kind of
like
it felt like sarna should have more
points and
you know nihal was really spent too much
time
yeah in the earlier segments but when i
see that night checkmate i forget about
all of that past stuff and i'm sorry oh
you do
yeah this guy's just you're you realize
you're at that point nine of five is
coming it's weird six two in the
presence of greatness and this is going
to be the last game of the segment
and the last game of the match end of
the entire tournament what will the last
move be of the tournaments
uh resignation because knight at five
you can't play queen f6 96 check wins
the queen
and here comes queen h6 otherwise
and rook takes that f5 rook g5 you might
have a rook stack here
yes mate it's made in a fitting
conclusion
to an unbelievable run by niho sarin and
such an impressive run of course by
alexis serrano as well
rook takes the it was made in two this
is also fine bishop h
saw no i don't do that to make so
got to alexi there but it was winning
anyway 18 to
7 the final score as nihal seren wins
the jscc
at performance for the ages robert yeah
he
saved his best for last and niall sarin
just
cruised honestly to the championship
what a what a worthy winner he is the
junior speed chess
championship you hear the word junior
but their age belies their strength
all of these players are exceptional
they are
world-class players and nihal sarin he
is just mesmerizing to watch absolutely
just no words to describe some of these
performances
and obviously a huge congratulations
also to
alexis sarna the bright young star from
russia who will now play the russian
higher league
he uh played fantastic uh not only in
this match but across the board
but succumbing to the uh just the
wizardry of the devil
neil sarin and for alexi he bows out of
the jscc
in the final match and i believe it's
his last time able to play because he's
20 which means he turns 21 he ages
out and for nihal he'll have many more
opportunities well perhaps by next year
he'll just qualify scc directly
and we are going to take a break we want
to get nihal sarn in on the call so that
we
we can interview him hear his thoughts
and hey maybe he'll
just be smiling because he has won a
place in the speeches championship we'll
be right back
for the interview from the junior
speechless championship match brought to
you by chess.com at chestnut.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are joined by the jscc champion
nihal sarin
and i have so many questions to ask you
but i'll start with this one there are
many
great moments by you in this match but
have you ever checkmated somebody with
a knight in two pawns against a knight
in two pawns like that
yeah that was a very strange one and it
just came by excellent of course i don't
calculate but
when i played knight f1 i saw that i
could just remove knight detention
congratulations that was a fantastic
performance all around
uh one thing that was particularly
impressive was your ability to
not only survive in acute time pressure
but also thrive and win a lot of games
with two
one second on the clock do you practice
that directly do you feel like what's
the sort of secret there
what do you do to keep yourself calm and
what do you do to develop that ability
um i think it's just by playing a lot of
bullets
and especially i played quite a lot of
ten plus one
like ten seconds yeah also played quite
a lot there i think
yeah yeah nothing can attest to your
wizardry there
yeah for sure and i mean nihal you just
won
yourself a payday but i think more
importantly for you as a competitor you
earned your entrance into the speed
chess championship
is there any super grand master that you
would particularly want to play
i mean we don't know what the field is
going to be yet but who's your dream
parent
i know it's slate for you i have just
one more question looking back at the
jscc and
your performance what moment will you
was it 97 mate what was your most
memorable match
or your most memorable moment that
powered you through to the final and to
victory
oh which knight this one made right well
the one the one that you just put on the
board knight 92 sorry 92
yeah maybe this one was the best
i don't remember anything well i i have
another question for you
nihal um you know your matchup against
anton smirnov was your closest one
do you think having that really tough
matchup early helped you because
after that the matches went completely
your way so it seemed like
you actually got better the deeper into
the tournament
you went yeah maybe like
that was a very tough match and yeah
then i was very happy to pull through so
maybe that energy guide me through them
well i mean we have nothing else to say
but congratulations there were so many
people
rooting for you so uh you have a lot of
fans out there i'm sure you've made many
more today
and we just look forward to seeing you
continue to shine and
well you're going to be the speed chess
championship so that's super exciting
congratulations
thank you well that
is your junior speed chess champion
nihal sarin
chess goals predictions they were
correct in the sense that nihal was the
champion
hard to bet against that guy honestly
just how strong
he was 18 to seven
in the final daniel what a performance
absolutely amazing his moves do the
talking he's
also confident and yet he's humble and
very mature and it's always a pleasure
to watch someone like that
and his moves really did a lot of
talking today in his previous matches
this was a performance for the ages
this was an incredible display of
brilliance in all areas
and what an incredible run this was by
me halsarn
he is just an absolute beast and he is
one of the qualifiers for the
speed chess championship which has a
hundred thousand dollar prize fund we
saw vladimir putin say have qualified
via the
speedchest super swiss uh there will be
the
bullet chess championship and an sec
invitational where people can earn their
spot
the placements i think are set as well
from the sec grand prix
maybe i i didn't actually look to see
you know who's there but i know nordie
back
abusive tarot hike marty rossian were
doing extremely well so we'll round it
out i'm sure they'll be
mentioned shortly but today it's all
about nihal sarin the
teenager from india a superstar
just he really did achieve excellence
throughout the jscc
we just have to congratulate him i i
really don't know how else we can
compliment the guy because as you said
his actions
spoke louder than any words we could say
absolutely they do and
india has been a chess powerhouse
putting out tons of talented young
players but nihal might be the star that
shines brightest
and he just confirmed that today he's
got such a bright future ahead of him
he's
you see his play you think he's been
around for a while but then you look and
he's only 16 years old he's got so many
more years of
incredible chess ahead of him what a
performance and what a tournament this
was really a privilege
and a treat uh to have had quartzite
seats uh to these displays of brilliance
yeah seriously
nihal sarin you can just you know that
this guy he's already amazing but you're
going to keep an eye out because he's
only going to ascend from here
and for alexis sarina it might be his
last opportunity in the jscc
but we're not done hearing from him
either we're absolutely super
strong he got through these tough
pairing after tough pairing yes of panko
samsevi and
jeffrey john just to make it to the
final that's an achievement in and of
itself
so we should congratulate him i know
it's not the way he wanted to end his
tournament
but he has a lot to be proud of as well
well absolutely there are a lot of mvps
nihal the mvp but
um close well i wouldn't even say close
behind another mvp
grandmaster robert has he wasn't a
participant but
uh he made it better for me oh wait he's
i'm commenting with him right now
i shouldn't refer to him in the third
person but this was such a treat to
watch and robert as usual
it's been an absolute pleasure i'm sad
that this is coming to an end
but it was amazing you know uh it is
quite sad that this event is over i
could
do so many more of these matches with
you dania it's been so fun
and you know before we sign off we'd be
remiss not to thank everybody who
continues to tune in whether you've been
watching on
twitch youtube chess tv we are so
appreciative of all of you
you make these matches even more fun for
us and i know the players
are personally thankful for your support
because they can't read your
messages during their streams but they
feel it it energizes them so thank you
so much
to our producer bick who's been with us
the entire way doing an amazing job
got to thank him and to the whole team
at chess.com and chesskid.com for
sponsoring this event
it makes it possible so on that note
we're going to sign off it's been
real everybody enjoy your days stay safe
and happy chessing bye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you